Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr.
44.
44. Ja, es hat natürlich wie immer etwas länger gedauert.
Warum hat das denn eigentlich so lange gedauert, diesmal, Frank?
Na du warst die ganze Zeit unterwegs.
Also hör mal, ich war überhaupt nicht unterwegs.
Na gut. Ja gut, ich muss zugeben, ich bin schuld, also ein bisschen schuld. Ich schreibe gerade an einem Sci-Fi und der wird als so genannter Polyplot erscheinen, also als in einem Format, was du auf dem Telefon lesen kannst, in einer App, die es dann halt erlaubt, dass man den Storyflow, die Umgebung, wie sich irgendwie Protagonistenverhalten innerhalb der Story beeinflussen kann. Also es gibt halt so Entscheidungen und alle möglichen anderen Dinge.
Ist das so wie Choose Your Own Adventure?
Das ist komplexer, weil du kannst tatsächlich in der, also beim Story schreiben, auch einzelne Worte mutieren, zum Beispiel in der Handlung. Also wenn halt zum Beispiel der Protagonist oder Protagonistin an irgendeiner Stelle entschieden hat, sich nicht zu essen, dann wird sie halt oder er im Laufe der Handlung halt schwächer oder hat halt irgendwie weniger Batterie auf seinem Exoskelett oder was auch immer. Also die Attribute der Welt verändern sich halt entsprechend der Auswahl von dem, was du als Leser-Leserin halt irgendwie dann halt entscheidest. Die Welt ist halt so eine relativ klassische Cypher-Punk-Story, so also halt so ein eher so Shadowrun angelehnt, aber ist tatsächlich dem Jean-Baptiste Hoop-Punk zuzuordnen. Das heißt also, es ist halt keine...
Dann notieren sie das hier im Kalender. Von Frank geht erstmalig Hoffnung aus.
Genau. Ja, also wenn ihr Bock habt, das zu lesen, die Webseite dazu heißt polyplot.io/gm. Das Buch heißt Gefährliche Menschen. Und es geht halt... Also der größte Story-Arc ist halt, dass so die Mächtigen der Welt halt einfach Angst haben davor, dass die Technologieentwicklung es ihnen unmöglicher macht, die Kontrolle darüber zu behalten, wie der Status Quo aussieht. Und da Technologieentwicklung aber zu verlangsamen oder anzuhalten so ein bisschen schwierig ist und halt stagnation riskiert beziehungsweise halt einfach nicht zu managen ist. Konzentrieren sich darauf halt Menschen mit besonders hoher Intelligenz und Tatkraft und Energie im Auge zu behalten. Also die gefährlichen Menschen, die halt im Zweifel das Problem wären, wenn sie die Hindernis an modernen Technologie bekommen.
Werden die nur beobachtet oder in die Armee eingezogen?
Na, du hast halt zwei Optionen eigentlich. Du kannst halt als gefährlicher Mensch entweder dich bei einer der Megacorps verdingen oder beim Start. Also sozusagen konform innerhalb des Systems sein. Oder du hast halt die ganze Zeit Pech. Du hast halt ständig eine Steuerprüfung. Deine Start-up-Finanzierung wird nix. Visa werden nicht genehmigt. Irgendwie interessanter Material und Geräte kannst du nicht kaufen. Also du bist halt sozusagen auf der Arschkartenliste. Du kriegst halt irgendwie keinen Fuß auf den Boden. Dann gibt es aber noch gefährliche Menschen, die da keinen Bock drauf haben und die halt außerhalb des Systems leben. Und in dieser Welt spielt das Buch. Die ist halt so ein Kollektivunterfangen. Es gibt halt irgendwie die Team Polyplot, was die Software schreibt. Ich mach den Text zusammen mit Christiane Hütte, die mir beibringt, wie man Geschichten schreibt, weil ich ja bisher nur sozusagen Sachbuchschreibererfahrungen habe. Das ist irgendwie für mich doch sehr interessant.
Wie lange dauert denn einmal durch Spielen? Das sind so die Datenpunkte, die man bei Videospielen abfragt.
Ja, ist schwer zu sagen, der Text ist noch nicht ganz fertig. Im Schnitt werden es wahrscheinlich so was wie 150, 180 Seiten lesen werden, wenn du einem der Branches und Flows über den Daumen folgst. Gibt ein paar kürzere, gibt ein paar längere, kann sich zwischendurch auch entscheiden.
Gibt es auch einen Speedrun gleich im Kapitel 1, eine Abkürzung nehmen?
Nee, den gibt es tatsächlich nicht. Und die Entscheidungen, die man treffen muss, sind tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen, die haben halt durchaus Implikation. Also es gibt halt harmlose Entscheidungen, es gibt halt nicht so harmlose Entscheidungen.
Aber alle sind sie gefährlich?
Nicht unbedingt. Manche sind doch nur unterhaltsam, aber naja, werdet ihr dann sehen, also wie gesagt, wer der Bock hat, dann klickt da mal hin. Die, ja, die Apps muss man sich dann halt dafür runterladen dann und ja.
Ja, Megacorps, das klingt alles so ein bisschen nach Shadowrun.
Ja, total. Also ist halt so ein bisschen so dieses Shadowrun-Setting, was wir jetzt auch in der realen Welt haben, nochmal ein bisschen nach vorne extrapoliert.
Gibt's auch eine Matrix, in die man sich einklingt?
Aus dramaturgischen Gründen gibt's natürlich AR und Holo und all diese ganzen Dinge, es gibt keine Matrix. Und ein Großteil der elektronischen Kommunikation der Leute, die außerhalb der Gesellschaft leben, findet in Standard-ASCII-Chats statt. Die sind doch einfach in... Oh, geil.
Also mit der Zukunft könnte ich ja direkt...
Die hat natürlich auch technische Gründe, weil es halt sehr viel einfacher ist, als ein Dialog in so einer Buchform in einem Chat.
Ja, Shadowrun. Shadowrun, ich kenne das, ist ein Fantasy- slash Sci-Fi-Rollenspiel, wo man in einer fiktionalen Zukunft, die nicht vollständig, aber weitgehend dystopisch ist, als Gruppe von Abenteurern sich verdingt und die übliche Arbeitslage für so einen Protagonisten in diesem Rollenspiel ist, dass man versucht, bei den Megakorps einzubrechen und Informationen frei zu hacken und die dann zu verkaufen. Und das ist schon lustigerweise relativ nah an dem Thema, um das es heute gehen soll. Wobei wir allerdings eher umso das tatsächlich schon von vornherein freie Wissen reden wollen. Nicht so sehr, um welches das erst freigehackt werden muss, aber viele von den Fragestellungen sind übertragbar. Auf dem Weg hier zur Aufnahme habe ich eine lustige Sache beobachtet in der S-Bahn. Und zwar saßen da neben mir zwei Schüler. Und die eine von denen hat dem anderen ihre Talking Points vorgelesen für einen Vortrag in Geschichte zur Industrialisierung. Und die inhaltlichen Punkte waren alle aus einer Perspektive, wie man sie nur rückblickend von heute haben kann, nämlich alles Umweltschutz. So nach dem Motto Ja und dann war das ganze Zeug in der Luft und das hat die Photosynthese behindert. Und dann sind irgendwie die Pflanzen gestorben und dann konnte man schlecht atmen und das gab Krankheiten. Und das Wasser war beeinträchtigt und dann gab es Fische sterben und das stimmt alles. Aber das war nicht das Problem damals, sondern es gab Kinderarbeit. Und die Leute sind am Arbeitsplatz gestorben, weil es keine Sicherheitsvorschriften gab. Und die Rente, wie wir sie heute verstehen, so alt sind die Leute einfach gar nicht geworden, dass das überhaupt eine Frage gewesen wäre. Und das finde ich eine interessante Diskussionsgrundlage, über die man mal reden kann, was eigentlich dieser Zugang zu praktisch dieser unbegrenzte Zugang zum Weltwissen mit unserer Gesellschaft macht. Und zwar sowohl als Gesellschaft, als auch mit den Individuen. Denn ich beobachte mich da selbst ganz gerne, gucke, was das ändert. Und einer meiner Eindrücke war, wobei das schon mit Telefonen anfing. Also mein erster Eindruck von Telefonen war, sobald die anfingen, Telefonnummern zu speichern, habe ich mir keine mehr gemerkt. Dadurch, dass der Zugang zu den Speichern mit den Telefonnummern so niederschwellig war, habe ich mir nichts mehr davon gemerkt, weil ich wusste, ich muss hier nur eine Tasse drücken. Und mit Wikipedia ist es auch so ein bisschen so. Ich beobachte mich selbst immer ganz eigentlich verstört dabei, wie ich Sachen, die ich mal eben nachgucken könnte, verschiebe. Weil die kann ich auch morgen nachgucken.
Also ich kenne dieses Phänomen, so die Telefonnummern, die ich noch aus dem Kopf weiß, sind alles Telefonnummern aus den 90ern, die noch gleich geblieben sind.
Aus der Zeit von vor Sprecher. Also meine ersten Telefonnummern kenne ich noch auswendig, die als man noch eine Wählscheibe hatte und so. Aber die danach nicht mehr.
Und also ich habe ja meine Telefonnummer auch irgendwie seit ungefähr, keine Ahnung, Mitte der 90er oder so. Eben auch, weil Leute, die sich halt gemerkt haben, gut, die ist auch gut zu merken, aber. Und also ich habe halt eher bei so Wissen, also bei so Standardwissen eher das Phänomen, dass ich das nicht verschiebe, es nachzugucken, aber mir die Details nicht mehr merke. Und sondern halt einfach nur so ein ungefähres, also so eine ungefähre Einordnung habe. Also gerade nehmen wir zum Beispiel Neurobiologie, wo ich halt manchmal interessieren mich da halt Sachen und dann lese ich die halt auch im Detail, verstehe sie auch im Detail, aber swappe dann dieses Detailwissen halt auch wieder raus, weil ich halt weiß, das hat mich jetzt gerade interessiert, damit ich halt das Gesamtsystem verstehen kann und weiß...
Das müssen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht Computerleuten erklären, was auswoppen heißt, oder?
Also ich merke es mir halt nicht im Detail. Ich weiß halt, es gibt es als ausgelagertes Wissen. Ich kann es halt jederzeit wieder nachsehen. Und dann folgt für mich daraus, dass ich zwar das endresultat dieses Gedankenprozesses und dieses Verstehen merke ich mir schon auch.
Die Einordnung, ne?
Naja, nicht nur die Einordnung, sondern auch das Endresultat. Metabolismusprozesse sind zum Beispiel super komplex. Und da gibt es halt wie so ein riesiges Uhrwerk von Dingen, die einander greifen und unter bestimmten Umständen ändert sich dieses Uhrwerk dann auch so einfach so. Aber der interessante Teil ist, was kommt rein, was kommt draus? Und unter welchen Umständen und welche groben Nebenwirkungen hat es denn so? Also was passiert, wenn du an diesem Rädchen drehst, ändert sich denn da was? Also wenn du dieses Medikament nimmst, zum Beispiel, welche Auswirkungen hat es denn auf dieses oder jenes so? Und aber am Ende merke ich mir dann halt in der Regel primär sozusagen so die ersten drei Absätze der Wikipedia und die Nebenwirkungen oder so. Also halt sozusagen so ganz oben, ganz unten so. Und was denn dazwischen ist, weiß ich, das steht da, wenn ich jetzt in Detailwissen kann ich es nachgucken, und dann ist es auch wieder schnell wieder erschließbar.
Das finde ich ja auch in Ordnung. Aber bei mir ist es dann teilweise so, dass ich Sachen ewig verschiebe. Dass ich nie dazu komme.
Also du guckst dir dann nicht an, oder wie?
Ich gucke mir das dann nie an, weil es immer gerade eine andere Sache gibt, die ich tun könnte und weil ich mir denke, das ist ja so und die da schwerlich, das kann ich auch irgendwann machen, wenn ich Zeit habe. Aber die habe ich dann halt nie.
Und dann kommst du in die deutsche Wikipedia und der Artikel ist weg. Oder auf einen Stop zu stoppen, wie du willst.
Ja, also ich verbringe inzwischen die meiste Wikipedia-Zeit in der englischen Wikipedia. Das stimmt.
Die deutsche Wikipedia ist leider einfach irgendwie, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass die deutsche Wikipedia hat sich zum Ziel gesetzt, zur Bildzeitung zu werden. Also halt einfach nur kein Artikel sollte mehr als 20 Zeilen haben, weil sonst irgendwie ist offensichtlich das Internet überfordert mit dem Speichern oder so.
Nee, also die haben auch durchaus lange Artikel. So ist das nicht.
Ja, das sind dann Artikel, die von einzelnen Leuten mit Zeilen und Klauen verteidigt werden, die halt noch irgendwie richtig alte Admin-Rites haben und halt irgendwie hinrechten für Respekt haben. Aber ganz viele Artikel werden halt einfach gnadenlos immer weiter zusammengekürzt, bis sie halt weg sind. So oder fast weg sind. Und ich glaube, das ist halt einfach so ein, also diese Explosionisten halten es mittlerweile wirklich für ein Verbrechen. Das sollte beendet werden.
Ja, ich sehe ganz lustige Parallelen übrigens. Es gibt ja dieses Phänomen, dass Weltwissen verloren geht, auch an anderer Stelle, nämlich bei digitaler Kunst, die dann mit irgendwelchen Kopierschutz-Scheiß versehen ist. Und dann kann man zwar eine Kopie archivieren, aber der Kopierschutz geht halt nicht. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt Projekte, alte DOS-Spiele in einem Emulator, im Browser zu machen. Und da muss dann irgendein Freiwilliger, irgendein armes Schwein den Kopierschutz raus machen. Sonst ginge das halt nicht. So, und ein anderes Problem beim Erhalten des Weltwissens ist, dass zwischenzeitlich einfach mit schlechtem Papier gedruckt wurde. Also das ist nicht nur böse Absicht, aber es gibt praktisch eine breite Front an ähnlich gelagerten Problemen, wo einfach die langfristige Betrachtung nie stattgefunden hat. So erzeugen wir hier gerade was, was langfristigen Wert hat und was wir für zukünftige Generationen erhalten sollen. Das spielt einfach überhaupt keine Rolle mehr im Vergleich zu können wir jetzt kurzfristig Kohle machen damit. Aber eigentlich ging es mir gar nicht um Wikipedia-Bashing, ob ich da natürlich immer gerne dabei bin.
Wenn wir schon mal dabei sind.
Ja, du warst völlig recht. Sondern mir ging es sozusagen anhand dieses Beispiels von der industriellen Revolution und dem Umweltschutz als Blickwinkel. Das ist ja eine Sache, die ich auch bei mir beobachten konnte und wo ich aktiv gegen zu steuern versuche. Aber das ist halt gar nicht so einfach, dass wenn ich irgendwas recherchiere, dass ich dann vor dem Recherchieren im Grunde schon mir überlegt habe, was da für eine Geschichte rauskommen soll. Ich bin voreingenommen. Früher war das so, also mit früher meine ich jetzt, in den 70ern oder 80ern oder so, da hast du halt einen sehr limitierten Zugang gehabt. Also wenn man wollte, konnte man in die Bibliothek gehen oder vielleicht haben die Eltern auch irgendwie ein Brocke aus oder so gehabt. Und man konnte schon Sachen nachschlagen, aber da gab es dann halt nicht zu jeder Perspektive Fakten.
Es gab das kanonische Wissen.
Sondern es gab das kanonische Wissen. Das heißt, du bist hingegangen, hast dich informiert. Was weiß ich, wie sich Bienen fortpflanzen? Und dann gab es halt so ist das. Ja, heute ist es so, wenn man losläuft und sagt, wie ist denn das mit der industriellen Revolution? Aber man fragt nach Umweltschutz Sachen, findet man eben auch unendlich viele Fakten. Das heißt, wenn man schon mit der mit der Vorannahme hingeht, dass man das jetzt aus Sicht des Umweltschutzes betrachten muss, hat man nicht den Eindruck, nur einen Teilaspekt abzudecken, sondern die pure Masse an Sachen, die man finden wird, vermittelt einem den Eindruck, das ordentlich abgedeckt zu haben.
Aber genau dasselbe hatten wir in der DDR halt auch. Erzähl doch mal. Da war es halt auch so, dass alles wurde aus der parteilichen Perspektive des Kampfes des Proletariats gegen den bösen Kapitalismus betrachtet. Das war halt die historische Einordnung von allem.
War das eigentlich der Kapitalismus oder der Imperialismus?
Na der Imperialismus natürlich, ja.
Aber ist das Synonym oder?
Naja, der Imperialismus ist natürlich der verkommenere und dem Faschismus zunehmendere Kapitalismus. Der halt seine Imperien baut. Aber diese parteiliche Betrachtung, also die Betrachtung der Realität aus einem bestimmten vor definierten Blickwinkel, ist ja nicht unbedingt was Schlechtes. Es führt ja dazu, dass die Dinge eine gewisse Ordnung haben. Du kannst damit halt, also wie erinnern funktioniert, ist ja irgendwie entweder du hast einen emotionalen Anker da drauf oder du kannst es halt, es passt in dein Gerüst, du kannst es halt in deine Welt irgendwie einordnen. So ne, gut, gibt noch ein paar andere Erinnerungsformen, aber das sind halt so die beiden großen Wesentlichen, die jetzt im Alltag relevant sind. Und diese Einordnung in ein größeres Gerüst wird dir natürlich einfacher gemacht, wenn du immer die Welterklärerperspektive aus dieser Sicht hast. Und wenn es jetzt halt irgendwie gerade Umweltschutz oder Klimaschutz ist, ist das vielleicht auch nicht so schlecht, das so zu betrachten. Du verlierst natürlich eine Menge Nuancen dabei und du wirst halt möglicherweise halt ganz wesentliche Aspekte, wie zum Beispiel, du sagst, okay, ich betrachte alles aus einer ökonomischen Perspektive, was ich in der Regel am interessantesten finde, nämlich was waren die ökonomischen Treiber für bestimmte Dinge. Weil dann verstehst du die Motivation der Leute. Wenn du noch weiter zurückgehst, was waren die religiösen Treiber davon? Weil Leute reagieren ja nicht immer nur rational, sondern ganz viele Sachen. Also gerade halt in der Geschichte vor, sagen wir mal so 1700, waren halt häufig religiös getrieben. Also es gab natürlich zugrunde liegende ökonomische Faktoren, die eine Rolle gespielt haben. Aber trotzdem gab es halt super irrationale Nummern, die sie halt in einem massiven Umfang gebracht haben, auch in einem großen Skalierungsfaktor gebracht haben, die halt einfach nur religiöse Flitze waren.
Da wäre ich aber vorsichtig, das irrational zu bezeichnen, weil einfach der Wissenstand so gering war. Aus heutiger Perspektive keine Frage.
Und zumal man auch damals, also einfaches Beispiel, wenn du halt anguckst, so Kirchen und Tempel. Ja. Wenn du die heute anguckst, siehst du halt irgendwie ein großes, schön aussehendes Haus, was dazu da war, halt irgendwie da seinen Gottesdienst zu machen. Das ist aber eine Perspektive, die nichts mit der Perspektive zur Zeit der Erbauung zu tun hat. Wenn die halt irgendwie zum Beispiel aus dem Mittelalter stammt oder von noch früher, weil da hatte die sehr viel mehr Funktionen. Da war es halt das Zentrum des sozialen Lebens. Da waren die Leute halt alle, mindestens zum Gottesdienst. Daraus folgte dann wiederum, dass die ökonomische Aktivität sich natürlich auch dahin verlagert hat. Wenn du an die Bibelgeschichte denkst von Jesus, der irgendwie die Geldwechsler aus dem Tempel geschmissen hat, na warum waren die Geldwechsler da? Weil die Menschen da waren, weil die Leute das Geld, was sie dem Tempel geben mussten, durfte nicht irgendein Geld sein, sondern es musste frei von irgendwelchen Symbolen von anderen Kaisern und sonst was sein, es musste neutrales Geld sein. Das heißt, wenn die da mit ihrem lokalen Geld ankamen zum Tempel, um irgendwie ihre Abgabe dazu machen oder ihr Opfer zu machen, mussten sie es vorher in ein Geld umtauschen. Ich glaube, es war eine syrische Drachmann oder so was, was sie dann da in dem Tempel abliefern konnten. Und dann saßen aber diese Geldwechsler natürlich da und die hatten halt Geld in allen möglichen Formen und Farben. Das heißt, die waren auch diejenigen, die noch andere Währungen untereinander tauschen konnten. Das heißt, diese ökonomische Verbindung von religiöser und ökonomischer Aktivität und die, dass also der, dieses, soll man, diese reine Betrachtung von ökonomische Sphäre, religiöse Sphäre, dass die nichts mehr zu tun hat, ist halt Quatsch. Na, du musst halt, musst halt die Gesamtheit betrachten, auch aus der Perspektive der Zeit. Du kannst sie natürlich ökonomisch, rein ökonomisch einordnen und sagen, okay, da war halt ein Ort, da kamen alle Leute hin, da haben die halt irgendwie ihr Geld getauscht. Also ist davor auch ein Markt entstanden, was ja auch so war. Und bei den europäischen Kirchen genau dasselbe Ding. Die Messen, also Messe hat ja die doppelte Bedeutung. Du hast einmal die Trade Show, also da, wo halt Firmen ihren Kram vorstellen. Und es war damals ja in der Regel eine Handelsmesse. Das heißt, du bist hingegangen und hast Zeug gekauft, auch in großen Mengen, und hast dein Zeug wieder mit zurückgenommen und dann verkauft. Und dann hattest du halt die Messe in der Kirche, also halt den Gottesdienst. Aber dass das das selbe Wort ist, weißt schon darauf hin, wie eng diese Verknüpfung von dieser Aktivitäten war.
Na und heute noch sind die meisten Marktplätze vor Kirchen, ne?
Genau. Also das hat ja...
Kein Zufall.
Aber nur, um sozusagen diesen Bogen noch mal kurz zuzumachen, der vielleicht jetzt gerade ein bisschen länger war, dass ich glaube, dass die Perspektive, mit der man auf Ereignisse guckt und in die man Fakten einordnet, ist immer nie vollständig neutral. Aber du kannst versuchen, dir darüber bewusst zu sein, was deine Perspektive ist. Also was sozusagen die Fakten, okay, die kannst du halt bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt relativ neutral sehen. Aber die Einordnung hängt dann natürlich immer davon ab, was ist der Rest. Also nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel ein einfaches Beispiel Lebensmittelskandale. Lebensmittelskandale, außer jetzt den Standard-Skandalen, zeichnen sich häufiger mittlerweile dadurch aus, dass unsere Messgeräte besser geworden sind. Das heißt, wir haben immer häufiger Verunreinigungen in Lebensmitteln, die vorher schon lange da waren, die immer da waren, die einfach prozessbedingt sind oder was auch immer, wo aber die Messmittel einfach über die Zeit besser geworden sind und Sensoren sind viel empfindlicher geworden. Und wenn wir dann sagen, wir haben gar keinen Grenzwert, weil dieser Stoff ist halt immer, willst du immer nicht in deinem Lebensmittel haben, dann heißt es, dass dein Grenzwert, also ein effektiver Grenzwert, mit dem du einen Skandal triggern kannst, fällt mit deiner, je weiter die Messgenauigkeit steigt. Und die Welt hat sich nicht verändert an dieser Stelle. Also es ist das selbe Lebensmittel aus dem selben Prozess, aus derselben Fabrik, mit denselben Rohstoffen, mit denselben Eigenschaften, was du schon zehn Jahre lang gegessen hast. Aber deine Messmittel sind besser geworden. Du kannst jetzt genauer hingucken und du findest raus, da sind dann halt noch irgendwie ein paar Nanogramm von irgendwas drin, was du echt nicht in deinem Essen haben willst. Die waren da aber immer drin. Trotzdem hat sich deine Perspektive plötzlich dahin verändert, zu sagen so, oh, das ist jetzt aber ein Skandal, da muss der Hersteller was tun.
Ist auch vielleicht so, dass wir teilweise jetzt erst wissen, wonach wir gucken sollen, ne?
Gibt's auch, ne? Aber an vielen Stellen hast du halt trotzdem dieses Phänomen, dass die verbesserten Möglichkeiten unsere Perspektive auf die Welt verändern und unsere Ansprüche an die Welt verändern. Und bei Umweltschutz ist es genau dasselbe, ne?
Ich finde übrigens Religion an der Stelle ein superspannendes Stichwort, weil nämlich früher, also früher hätte man dieses Phänomen der Religion zugeschrieben, dass man sagt, okay, die Leute sehen zwar die Fakten, aber ihr Auge ist getrübt, weil sie irgendeiner Ideologie angehören, ob das jetzt religiös oder Kommunismus ist. Aber so, dass man sozusagen voreingenommen durch eine Weltbildkonstruktion Sachen betrachtet, das ist eine Sache, die ich zum ersten Mal als Kritik an der Religion gehört habe. Später dann an an politischen Ideologien. Und heute haben wir das halt an sozusagen auf individueller Ebene und gar nicht so gesellschaftsweit. Das finde ich schon eine interessante Entwicklung. Wir haben ja in Alternativlos auch schon über den Sokoff geredet. Der hat mich ja immer noch verfolgt, der Putin Berater. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, das ist eigentlich auch eine Sache, die man als Waffe gegen Menschen benutzen kann, dass man sagt, okay, die Fakten sind jetzt für jeden im Zugriff. Das war ja früher nicht so. Früher konnte man einfach sagen, nö, das war nicht so. Und dann haben die Leute das nicht prüfen können und mussten mir halt glauben. Der Staat konnte einfach lügen oder die Kirche konnte einfach lügen. Die Zeiten sind jetzt vorbei, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass die weniger mächtig geworden sind, sondern sie greifen jetzt eben nicht mehr die Fakten an, sondern die Deutung. Also auf der einen Seite durch selektive Auswahl der Fakten, auf der anderen Seite durch das Sokoff-Verfahren, dass man den Markt flutet mit Behauptungen und Fakten und dass man einfach übrigens auch ursprünglich aus der Religion das Verfahren, der Fachbegriff dafür heißt Gisch-Galopp. Also galoppieren wie ein Pferd. Und Gisch war ein evangelikaler Fernsehprediger, wenn ich mich jetzt gerade richtig erinnere. Der so ein, die Erde ist 6000 Jahre alt Typ. Und der hat halt schneller neue Lügen verbreiten können, als man seine alten Lügen entwerten konnte. Ja, also die Strategie ist nicht neu von Sokoff. Aber so diesen Shift finde ich hochinteressant, dass wir jetzt nicht mehr einfach mit den Fakten lügen, sondern dass wir jetzt mit der Deutung lügen. Und da gibt es weniger Verteidigungsstrategien gegen, ist mein Eindruck. Und die Frage ist, ob das besser wird, wenn man die Fakten labeln würde, sage ich jetzt mal. Dass du irgendwie sagst, okay, das ist jetzt hier ein Essay über die Industrialisierung aus Sicht des Umweltschutzes. Hilft das, meinst du?
Also, ich glaube, dass der, diese Betrachtung Umweltschutz...
Die ist ja nicht blöde, die ist aber halt aus einer Perspektive, die erst jetzt, erst aus heutiger Sicht spielt Umweltschutz eine Rolle. Ja, ich, also ich, als um das zu illustrieren, kann man nach Tschernobyl gucken, finde ich. Ja, in Tschernobyl ist ja eine große Strahlung und die Menschen sind evakuiert und alle haben gedacht, da ist jetzt Todeszone und das stimmt gar nicht. Mit der Natur geht es prächtig, ja, weil die Pflanzen und Tiere werden nicht alt genug, um an Krebs zu sterben. Die leben nicht lang genug und ähnlich war das in der Industrialisierung. Die Leute sind einfach nicht, nicht alt genug geworden, um an dem Umweltschäden zu sterben.
Ja, das stimmt nicht ganz. Also tatsächlich ist es so, dass die während der Industrialisierung sind halt schon, also ich meine gerade die Bergleute und so und die.
Ja, aber das sind ja, das sind ja fehlende Sicherheitsvorschriften, ist jetzt meine Deutung davon.
Das ist ja nicht, die sind einfach an Silikose verreckt.
Na klar.
Also halt an Staub, an Umweltverschmutzung.
Na ja.
Umweltverschmutzung.
In der Mine.
Ja, und aber auch um von dem Rauch. Ich meine, guck dir an, was in den Städten damals los war.
Na ja, gut. Aber das ist ja heute teilweise immer noch so.
Also ich hab neulich schon einen Unterschied zu irgendwie.
Ja, natürlich. Also die Qualität war unter anderem keine Frage. Aber das Leute mit Kohle ohne Filter heizen gibt es auch heute noch. Also in gewissen Stadtteilen von Berlin. Hier gerade, wo wir aufnehmen, rochst auch gerade erst mal nach Kohle, als ich aus der...
Das ist aber schon kein Vergleich mit früher.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber also das ist nicht so, dass wir das Problem losgeworden sind.
Also ich glaube, dass diese Art der Betrachtung und die Priorisierung von Wichtigkeit von einzelnen Themen, also nehmen wir mal jetzt Klimaschutz, Umweltschutz, die jetzt halt zu dominierenden Themen geworden sind, weil die Sicht darauf sich verändert hat. Also man sagt, also man ist jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwie nicht schon länger klar ist, dass halt irgendwie Umweltbelastung halt irgendwie langfristig nicht gut ist. Aber wir haben halt in der Risikobetrachtung lange Zeit gesagt, okay, wir nehmen das halt hin, weil wir davon a. ausgehen, dass das Risiko halt nicht so groß ist und b. dass im Zweifel halt in der Betrachtung irgendwie, was kann man daraus kriegen, was kann man daraus irgendwie, also welche Schäden entstehen, hat man das Risiko halt akzeptiert. Also nehmen wir ein klassisches Beispiel dafür in so einer Risikoabwägung. Ist halt Plastoverpackung von Lebensmitteln. Also innerhalb der industrialisierten Welt ist gerade so, weil wir müssen irgendwie weniger Plaste verbrauchen, weil Plaste halt irgendwie ist halt schlechtlanden, Ozeanmikroplaste und so weiter und so fort. Wenn wir in die Zeit zurückdenken vor Plasteverpackung von Lebensmitteln, da hatten wir jedes Jahr tausende Tote durch Lebensmittelvergiftung. Weil die, also tatsächlich einfach das Einschweißen von Lebensmitteln unter Vakuum in Plaste führt halt einfach dazu, dass du diese Lebensmittel transportiert bekommst. Das wäre mit Konservierungsmitteln. Im Westen haben wir halt irgendwie jetzt dieses Ding, irgendwie wir wollen keine Lebensmittel mit Konservierungsmitteln mehr haben, weil die halt gefühlt irgendwie schlecht sind. Vor Konservierungsstoffen sind die Leute gestorben, wie die fliegen an verdorbenen Lebensmitteln.
Na und, weil unsere Logistikpipeline jetzt alles sehr zeitlich...
Na jetzt kann man halt voll in Überlegung machen, sagt man okay. Im Westen brauchen wir möglicherweise einiges davon. Nicht alles davon, aber einiges davon nicht mehr, weil wir es mit anderen Technologien, nämlich geschlossene Kühlkette zum Beispiel und Tracking und irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass der Strom immer an ist und die Kühlschränke immer laufen und die Zeug halt einfach nicht warm wird, lösen können. Deswegen brauchen wir möglicherweise nicht mehr so viele Konservierungsmittel. Was wir damit uns erkaufen ist quasi zu sagen, okay wir haben halt weniger Plaste, wir haben weniger Konservierungsmittel, vielleicht unsere Lebensmittel-Tolle hinterher. Aber das ganze System ist natürlich inherent fragil, weil es heißt dann halt, wenn da irgendwas passiert in dieser extrem komplexen Kette, dann wird das Zeug halt entweder schlecht, wenn du noch Glück hast und es merkst, oder ist halt wieder tote. Und das ist halt so eine Frage, wo man halt als Gesellschaft auch extrem schwer darüber diskutieren kann. Nämlich nimmt man bestimmte Nachteile in Kauf, also macht man halt eine Risikoabwägung, bei der man sagt hinterher, okay, was ist der Trade-off? Was bekomme ich dafür als Gesellschaft oder als Individuum? Und nehme ich dafür bestimmte Nachteile in Kauf? Also einfaches Beispiel, wenn du halt irgendwie in der Lebensmittelzubereitung mit bestimmten Stoffen bestimmte Temperaturen überschreitest, dann entstehen halt Stoffe, die können möglicherweise ein bisschen krebserregend sein. Die schmecken aber auch geiler.
Meinst du jetzt auch diese Pommes-Fett-Dinger, die da...
Na diese Acrylamidsache war vermeidbar so, aber wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt eine Currywurst holst, heutzutage hast du halt... Dann macht der mir Currywurst kaputt. Früher waren die Currywürste halt einfach knuspriger, weil die halt in viel heißerem Fett gebraten wurden. Und das ist jetzt halt verboten, wegen irgendwie Acrylamid und so weiter. Jetzt sind die halt alle so ein bisschen lasch. Du musst halt überlegen, was ist der Trade-off? In dem Fall hat halt irgendwie die Regulierung den Trade-off für dich übernommen und gesagt, das ist jetzt halt so. Und wenn du eine knusprige Currywurst musst, dann musst du dir zu Hause halt irgendwie zu Tode braten, wenn du das so willst. Aber das ist halt so, daraus diese Abwägung zu treffen, ist natürlich auch eine Frage. Macht die Gesellschaft das für dich? Oder kannst du das individuell entscheiden?
Also zwei Sachen. Erstens glaube ich ja, dass der Umweltschutz deswegen jetzt so häufig und gern diskutiert wird, weil wir akzeptiert haben, dass das eine Sache ist, wo das Individuum nicht nur was tun kann, sondern was tun muss. Was man auch sehr kritisch sehen kann, ich sehe das teilweise sehr kritisch, weil das dazu führt, dass wir die Industrie nicht mehr in der eh zustehenden Genauigkeit betrachten. Aber das ist ein Grund, warum viele Leute jetzt über Umweltschutz reden und das wir wichtig halten, weil sie glauben, da kann ich jetzt auch was tun. Während, sagen wir mal, bei dem Schwefelausstoß von Containerschiffen, da sieht sich der Einzelne nicht in der Rolle irgendwas zu ändern. Die andere Sache, die ich bei diesen Abwägungen immer beobachte, ist, dass Leute Sachen einfach als implizit ausgeschlossen schon annehmen und das daher gar nicht in ihrer Abwägung auftaucht. Ja, also zum Beispiel jetzt zu sagen, okay, da sind früher Leute dran gestorben, deswegen machen wir das nicht mehr so, dass das würden viele Leute gar nicht ansprechen, die das offenbar da haben und wissen und die anderen wissen es halt nicht und kennen dann den Teil der Abwägungen nicht. Also ich finde, man muss da sehr vorsichtig sein damit, wenn man so was diskutiert. Nicht nur, weil das implizit unter den Tisch fällt, sondern teilweise auch, weil es Denkverbote gibt. Ja, einige Sachen darf man gar nicht mehr ansprechen. Ich sage jetzt mal irgendwie Tierversuche in der Kosmetik zum Beispiel. Da ist eine Diskussion über die Abwägung im Grunde gar nicht mehr möglich, weil die Sache so toxisch geworden ist insgesamt. Daher, also Abwägung finde ich eine gute Sache, aber mein Eindruck ist ja gerade, dass durch diesen freien Zugriff auf das Weltwissen ich nicht merke, wenn ich nur einen winzigen Teil des großen Bildes sehe. Ich habe trotzdem das Gefühl, ich bin gut informiert, aber ich habe halt nur einen winzigen Teil gesehen und kann deswegen eigentlich die Abwägung gar nicht machen. Das finde ich heutzutage eigentlich das größere Problem. Jetzt habe ich endlich die Fakten alle, theoretisch, aber du weißt ja nicht, wann du fertig bist mit Fakten sammeln.
Nein, nie. Also das kannst du relativ klar sagen.
Naja, aber dass du zumindest sagen kannst, okay, ich habe jetzt genug, um dieses Problem zu entscheiden. Selbst das ist ja schon ein Problem in der Praxis.
Also ich glaube, dass die Frage der Wahl der Perspektive auf Vorgänge oder Fakten, da muss man halt so ein bisschen unterscheiden. Du hast, wenn du in die Wissenschaft guckst, also einfach Naturwissenschaften, auch da hast du ja das Phänomen, dass die Perspektive und die Erkenntnisse, die daraus gezogen werden, im Wesentlichen nur unser Messinstrument bestimmt werden. Also wir haben halt Dinge, wo wir jetzt mehr wissen, weil wir bessere Messinstrumenten haben. Aber wir können an einigen Stellen können wir auch nur sagen, das ist eine Approximation. Wir können ungefähr aus dem, was wir messen können, folgern, was da jetzt so wahrscheinlich passiert und dann eine Theorie drumherum bauen. Und dann muss man halt eigentlich nur aufpassen. Und das finde ich immer den wichtigen Teil, dass allen klar ist, eine Hypothese oder eine Theorie sind kein gesichertes Wissen. Das ist unser momentaner bester Stand der Erkenntnis.
Aber das kannst du doch immer sagen. Nee, aber selbst wenn du einen Beweis dafür hast, dass das korrekt ist, kann es sein, dass du einen Teil übersehen hast.
Das geht halt aber verloren. Und zwar überall. Das ist halt so dieses Annehmen davon, dass es Gewissheiten gibt. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Ding, was mit dem Ende der Postmoderne zu tun hat.
Du bist jetzt auf einer sehr tiefen Schicht, will ich mal behaupten. Wird das so aussehen? Also ich habe mir Sorgen gemacht, dass ich auf den Schichten darüber aus ideologischen Gründen nur einen Ausschnitt kriege. Weil eben schon der, der die Seite geschrieben hat, die ich jetzt gefunden habe, weil der auch nur einen Ausschnitt hatte. Und das ist mir mittlerweile gar nicht...
Da wollte ich gerade hin, weil letztendlich ist ja die Lehrmeinung. Ja. Also zu sagen...
Moment, ich meine aber er hat den Ausschnitt nicht, weil er das nicht besser wusste, sondern weil er eine Ideologie hat.
Genau, aber eine Lehrmeinung ist eine Ideologie. Also wenn du halt sagst, okay, das ist halt jetzt eine Lehrmeinung, die sagt, okay, das ist unser momentan gesicherter Stand der Erkenntnis und darauf haben sich alle geeinigt. Dann ist halt so, also sozusagen wie bei den Juristen, gibt es halt irgendwie auch dieses, wie heißt es, Herrschende Rechtsmeinung. Genau das selbe Spiel. Also sagst halt irgendwie, man hat sich mehrheitlich darauf geeinigt, dass das jetzt halt die Wahrheit ist. Und das kann man ja machen, weil du brauchst halt so eine Abkürzung, damit du halt irgendwie vorangehen kannst, dass du neue Sachen darauf aufbauen kannst und so weiter und so fort. Aber das Problem ist halt in dem Augenblick, wo es halt dann immer schwieriger wird, das zu hinterfragen, hört die Erkenntnis irgendwann auf.
Ja, dann ist ja auch eine Dogmatik.
Aber das Problem ist halt, genau diese Balance zu finden. Du musst halt irgendwann mal aufhören zu fragen, damit du weitergehen kannst. Du kannst halt nicht immer noch versuchen, immer weiter zu buddeln. Kannst du natürlich, wenn du Langeweile hast und dich jemand dafür bezahlt. Aber letzten Endes wirst du irgendwann eine Abstraktionsebene nehmen und sagen, okay, das ist jetzt das Wissen. Nehmen wir mal Klimawandel. Also da haben wir jetzt so die Diskussion darum. Klar kannst du sagen, okay, hier wir haben halt noch irgendwie die und die Faktoren und wir wissen es nicht ganz genau, ob es jetzt irgendwie doch noch einen Einfluss irgendwie von der Sonnenkonstellation gibt. Wir wissen nicht ganz genau, wie viel die Ozeane absorbieren. Da gibt es irgendwie eine große Schwankungsbandbreite. Wir wissen, wie es mit den mit den Torfmuren ist, so ungefähr, aber halt auch nicht so ganz genau im Detail. Es gibt jetzt eine Menge große Unbekannte, aber trotzdem man sich grob drauf gar nicht sagen soll, okay, wir müssen jetzt mal was tun, weil die Folgen sind sonst unangenehm.
Da gibt es aber auch noch diesen Fraktaleffekt. Ja, genau, aber du kannst beliebig ranzoomen und es wird nicht weniger schminkig.
Lassen wir ganz kurz mal den Denken zu Ende führen. Wie es sich darauf einigen, dass es jetzt eine Priorität gibt, weil die Grundgesamtheit der wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse, der Messdaten, die wir haben, alle in eine Richtung weist. Ja, selbst wenn es einzelne Outlier gibt, aber es ist halt vollkommen klar, da passiert wird, das sieht nicht so gut aus. Wir müssen uns als Menschheit darum kümmern, weil, wenn wir es nicht tun, sind die Folgen möglicherweise eher so ein bisschen katastrophal. Diese Erkenntnis hat sich jetzt in der Wissenschaftswelt festgesetzt. Es gibt einzelne Leute, die bestreiten das, weil da kann man auch eine Karriere draus bauen. Niemand sagt, ich bin der Outlier. Es gibt andere Leute, die haben mehr Nuancen, die sagen, okay, das ist jetzt noch nicht ganz so schlimm und da gibt es noch die Möglichkeit, mit Mitigation was zu reißen und so. Dann kann man sich darüber aber unterhalten, was sind die Folgerungen daraus? In dem Augenblick, wo man zumindest sich auf ein grobes Faktengruß geeinigt hat. Du kannst natürlich immer noch die Fakten bestreiten und sagen, ist ja gar nicht so. Dann pickst du dir irgendwas ganz unten aus dieser fraktalen Betrachtung raus, wo du ganz reingezoomt hast und sagst, hier, da hat es aber geschneit, statt 15 Grad wärmer zu werden. Dann beschäftigst du damit dann wieder irgendwelche Wissenschaftler, die dir sagen, ja, das hat deswegen geschneit, weil es an der Stelle wärmer geworden ist. Dadurch hat sich die Luftsirkulation geändert. Dadurch gab es einen Kälteeinbruch. Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich, passt genau ins Modell. Vielen Dank dafür, dass du irgendwie zwei Wochen unserer Lebenszeit mit einer blöden Aussage verbraucht hast.
Das ist übrigens auch der Gischt-Erlaubnis, dass du losgehst und schneller Fragen stellst, als sie beantwortet werden können.
Genau. Und das ist halt dieses Problem, das wir gerade haben, ist, dass viele Leute sind davon mittlerweile genervt. Die wollen eigentlich gewiss halten. Die wollen wieder, dass klar ist, da ist vorne, das ist das Ziel. Das ist irgendwie das, was notwendig ist.
So, und das ist ja eigentlich die Frage, bei der es mir in dieser Sendung ging. Ob nicht unser freier Zugang zu allen Fakten dazu geführt hat, dass wir im Grunde orientierungslos im Meer schwimmen. Und dass wir im Grunde gar kein Interesse an mehr Fakten haben, weil uns die Fakten, die wir haben, schon nicht geholfen haben, eine Orientierung zu finden. Ja, das wäre jetzt eigentlich mehr als früher.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute haben einen Mangel an Prioritäten. Weil natürlich hast du halt, weil sie haben es halt nicht gelernt, weil der in dem Zeitalter vor dem Internet als der Zugang zu Fakten schwierig und teuer war. Also ich kann mich noch genau erinnern. Ich musste, wenn ich irgendwie westliche Computerzeitschriften lesen wollte, musste ich nach Mitte fahren in die Stadt Bibliothek und mir diese z.B. CT oder wie hießen sie, oder Microcomputer oder so, diese alten Zeitungen, die es damals so gab, mit lesen wollte, um so ein bisschen up-to-date zu bleiben. Dann kam die auf Mikrofisch. Also das heißt also auf so einen ausbelichteten Film, den man dann in so ein Lesegerät gelegt hat, wo man dann davor gesessen hat und das dann halt so seitenweise da durchgescortet hat.
Mit einer riesigen Linse.
Das war so ein Projektionsbildschirm.
Ja total super die Teile.
Und das war halt Aufwand. Also es hat mich also eine CT zu lesen, hat mich eigentlich den gesamten Tag nach der Schule beschäftigt. Mit dahin fahren, ausleihen, drauf warten, dass es halt irgendwie aus dem Lager hochgeholt wird, dann irgendwie eine freie Mikrofisch-Lasestation finden, dann halt da durchscrollen und irgendwie, oder halt dann eben im Index nachgucken. Also es gab ja Stichwortindizes, wo du halt dann einfach nachgucken konntest, in welchen Büchern kommen welche Stichworte vor. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es das heute immer noch gibt, aber früher hast du halt irgendwie einen...
Einen Zettelkasten, riesiger, oder?
Genau, so riesige Zettelkästen, wo du halt die wesentlichen Stichworte, zu denen dieses Buch gehörte, also die Verschlagwortung des Buches, wo doch der Zeitschrift drin war. Und da sind Leute halt hingegangen und haben diese Schlagwortkartei dann halt geupdatet.
Abfällig faszinierend.
Und dann kann man sich heute kaum noch vorstellen. Und dann bist du halt hingegangen, hast halt irgendwie das richtige Schlagwort gesucht, gesagt, okay, hier sind die 15 Einträge, die es dazu gibt. Dann hast du einen Leischern ausgefüllt für irgendwie die drei Bücher und die eine Zeitschrift, die du dazu haben wolltest. Bist dann da hingegangen, hast eine Weile gewartet, bis der Kram dann irgendwie von unten aus dem Magazin hochkam. Dann hast du dich dann in den Lesesaal gesetzt und die gelesen. Es gab noch eine Handbibliothek, wo die Standardwerke standen. Wenn du ein bisschen speziell unterwegs warst, musstest du diesen Aufwand treiben. Manchmal war die halt ausgeliehen, dann musstest du halt warten. Dann hast du keinen sofortigen Zugriff gehabt. Was aber bedeutete, dass dadurch, dass der Zugang zum Wissen so zeitintensiv war, also kostlich, musstest du dir genau überlegen, was du tust. Und das hast du vorher überlegt. Du hast nicht irgendwie random browsing. Ich scroll hier mal durch. So bei Zeitschriften schon. Wenn du eine Sache dir geholt hast, dann hast du noch den Rest der Zeitschrift durchgelottert.
Hab ich aber auch gemacht in der Uni Bibliothek, dass ich einfach die Regale entlanggegangen bin.
Das ist halt der Vorteil von Handbibliothek, dass du halt irgendwie das so random browser machen kannst. Ich meine, ich hab das halt, als ich damals studiert habe, habe ich Informationswissenschaften studiert und das war halt irgendwie in der FU. Und da war halt das direkt daneben Bibliothek der Medienwissenschaften und des Publicistikinstitutes. Und die hatten halt alle wesentlichen deutschsprachigen Publikumszeitschriften seit deren Gründung, also seit dem Ende der 40er oder so. Ich weiß nicht, nachdem wann die da so rausgekommen waren.
Das ist echt ein krasses Gefühl, wenn du da in der Handausleihe einfach langläufst.
Und nimmst dir halt so ein Spiegel von 1956 irgendwie den Band aus dem Regal.
Ja, unfassbar. Ja, also aber dieses Gefühl habe ich ja auch gehabt im Internet. Also am Anfang gar nicht bei... Vor den Suchmaschinen gab es ja... Yahoo ist damit bekannt geworden, dass sie eigentlich so eine Art Index hatten. Also genau so eine Verschlagwortung. Ja, aber also das bringt mich gleich zur nächsten Frage. Weil das ist ja eine These, die man geringlich hört. Wenn der Zugang zu dem Wissen zu kostenlos ist, ob es dann den Wert, den man dem Wissen beimisst, auch senkt?
Das halte ich für eine Bullshit-Frage. Weil der Wert bemisst sich immer daran, was es für dich in dieser Situation, für diese Fragestellung beantwortet. Das ist halt genau das, was ich gerade meinte, dass die Priorität, also das Verlernen von Priorisierung und der damit einhergehenden Konzentration, ist halt das große Problem. Weil du hast halt dadurch, dass du halt den, den Instant-Zugriff, das Gefühl des Instant-Zugriffs zu wissen hast, weil es ist ja nicht so, dass du alles Wissen wirklich im Internet findest. Das stimmt ja schlicht nicht, weil da sind halt Paywalls dazwischen, da sind irgendwie Bücher, die halt nicht digital vorhanden sind, nach denen du relativ mühsam suchen musst. Du hast den Event Horizon, das heißt also alles, was vorher nicht digitalisiert wurde, der Event Horizon ist momentan so zwischen 1996 und 2003. Also dass Werke oder Informationen, die damals entstanden sind, bzw. die davor entstanden sind, nur sehr unverständlich digital vorliegen. Dass du die halt auch mittlerweile als schwierig empfindest, damit umzugehen. Nehme an, du suchst ein Buch, du findest es sogar online, aber es ist halt nur ein Scan von Images. Du kannst nicht darin suchen, weil es halt irgendwie nicht OCRt wurde. So, dann ist es halt schon so, eigentlich will man sich dann damit auch nicht mehr befassen, weil halt deinen Arbeitsmodus, nämlich nach Stichworten, in größeren Textgruppen auszusuchen, um den Teil zu finden, der dich jetzt eigentlich gerade interessiert, der geht dann halt nicht. Du musst dann halt dieses Buch lesen.
Ja, aber das ist doch genau die These nur anders formuliert, dass so sozusagen dadurch, dass es mit mehr Kosten verbunden ist, muss sozusagen der Return on Investment auch höher sein, damit du dich damit auseinandersetzt.
Genau, aber das heißt halt wiederum, dass du deine Auswahl sorgfältiger triffst.
Ja, ja, das ist ja auch.
Und das hast du jetzt halt nicht mehr. Also ich glaube, wozu diese fallenden Kosten des Zugangs zu Wissens führt dazu, dass du mehrere Effekte hast. Zum einen diesen, was du vorhin beschrieben hast, ich gucke das irgendwann später nach. Der zweite ist, dass du davon ausgehst, dass die Einarbeitung in ein neues Wissensgebiet relativ preiswert ist, was Zeit angeht. Ist es aber nie.
Stimmt aber nicht, genau.
Stimmt einfach nicht. Du kannst halt zwar dir relativ schnell einen Überblick verschaffen darüber, was da so passiert und was wichtig ist, aber bist du wirklich da was kannst und Bescheid weißt und irgendwie alle Nuancen kennst und die Geschichte kennst und die Einordnung dir es möglich macht, da drin was Neues zu schaffen. Die Zeit ist nicht geschrumpft. Es ist nur einfacher geworden, den Anfang zu machen. Also du willst dich halt in CNC-Fresen einarbeiten. Dann kannst du dir heute tausende Stunden YouTube-Videos dazu angucken, wo dir jedes einzelne Detail erklärt wird.
Das ist übrigens ein Effekt, den ich bei mir beobachte, dass ich überhaupt keine Zeit mir nehme, um Sachen als Video zu gucken. Wenn mir jemand irgendwie was schickt und es ist ein Link auf eine Zeitung und das kann ich irgendwie kurz überfliegen, dann mach ich das. Aber wenn mir jemand ein YouTube-Video von zwei Stunden schickt, dann sag ich, pff, ja. Selbst wenn es zehn Minuten sind, sag ich, ach komm. Also meine Ansprüche daran, wie Wissen sein müssen, damit ich willens bin, mich damit auseinanderzusetzen, die sind nämlich auch, haben sich geändert. Dadurch, dass der Durchschnitt runtergegangen ist, empfinde ich das jetzt eher als sozusagen eine Zumutung. Wenn ein längerfristiges Commitment von mir verlangt wird. Und ich glaube, das führt auch dazu, dass ich weniger willens bin, mir neue Gebiete anzugucken, weil ich halt doch merke, okay, da müsste ich jetzt aber mehr Zeit investieren. Und in der Zeit, wo ich mich aber in einen Bereich einarbeite, könnte ich aber hundert Bereiche überfliegen. Und dann hör ich halt auf, Sachen zu machen, jenseits von überfliegen, weil das halt so viel schneller geht inzwischen.
Ja, aber trotzdem...
Was wir brauchen, auch eine Cypherpunk-Idee übrigens, sind so Chips, die man sich mit Wissen einfach einklingt und dann weiß man das halt, was brauchen wir.
Genau, die klassische Szene aus Matrix, so.
Ja.
Aber ich glaube, dass der Ausweg daraus ist, sich zu konzentrieren. Und das heißt zu sagen, wenn ich was... Also klar, wenn es halt nur so fliegt an dir vorbei, du willst mal kurz wissen, worum es geht, klar, kein Problem. Aber wenn du das Gefühl haben willst, auch von befriedigung, von Selbstwirksamkeit, von ich kann das jetzt wirklich. Ich bin tatsächlich nicht nur ein blöder Amateur da drin, der sich mal kurz die Wikipedia-Seite durchgelesen hat, sondern ich kann da wirklich was. Dann musst du dir ein Projekt suchen, im Rahmen von dem du das wirkliche Wissen brauchst. Du musst dir irgendwas suchen, wo du sagst, ich baue mir jetzt keine Ahnung, was es ist. Oder ich schreibe mal ein Buch dazu. Oder ich finde irgendwas raus, ich recherchiere irgendwas, um dann darüber einen Artikel zu schreiben. Was dich dazu zwingt, dich wirklich einzuarbeiten, im Sinne von wirklich irgendwie in den Großteil des Materials, was es dazu gibt, zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, die wichtigen Teile zu sichten, dich an Detailprobleme aufzureiben, dafür Lösungen selber zu finden. Oder diese Detailprobleme, also die Lösung für diese Detailprobleme in der großen Internetmüllhalde zu finden. Dich mit anderen Leuten auseinanderzusetzen, die an demselben Problem arbeiten. Und dafür funktioniert dann nämlich zum Beispiel auch wieder YouTube super. Also gerade, also jetzt, man bleibt aber bei diesem Beispiel halt irgendwie so CNC-Machine-ing.
Ja, also ich wollte nicht sagen, dass das nichts bringt. Ich wollte nur sagen, ich hab diesen Impuls.
Genau. Und muss den aktiv bekämpfen. Aber der Punkt, wo du dir auch ein YouTube-Video reintun würdest, ist, wenn du weißt, die Person, die in diesem YouTube-Video redet, hat wirklich Ahnung von dem, was sie sagt. Ist nicht nur so ein Random Dude, sondern jemand, der schon seit fünf Jahren mit diesem Thema Zeit verbringt.
Nicht nur ein Reaction-Video.
Genau. Ist halt nicht nur ein irgendwie...
Unboxing.
Unboxing von irgendwie, keine Ahnung, sondern halt jemand, der dir erklärt, warum du dein Kühlflussmittelzufluss irgendwie so und so machen musst, damit dir dein Fräser nicht abbrennt. So oder was auch immer gerade dein Top ist, ja? Dann bist du auch bereit, dir diese Zeit ran zu tun. Und ich glaube, daran liegt halt diese Kunst, sich einfach Aufgaben zu setzen, die dich dazu zwingen, wenn du sie wirklich gut lösen willst, dich mit einer Materie intensiv zu beschäftigen und da nicht nur drüber zu skimmen.
Es gibt da noch einen Effekt, den ich wichtig finde an der Stelle, weil sich nämlich die Arbeitsweise auch geändert hat. Früher war das so, du gehst in die Bibliothek und während du in der Bibliothek bist, kriegst du keine Mails und das ruft dich keiner an, sondern du hast halt das Buch und einen Tisch. Und das ist eine Umgebung, in der man auch Sachen lernen kann. Da hast du automatisch eine Konzentration. Aber heute, wenn du an deinem Rechner sitzt und dann ist vielleicht noch ein Tab mit Facebook offen oder was weiß ich, irgendwie Twitter, soziale Netzwerke, irgendwo bimmelt ein Slack, irgendwas bewegt sich immer. Also ich glaube, das ist auch eine Sache, die wirklich abträglich ist gegenüber dem tatsächlichen Tiefenwissen. Dass man sich die Zeit gar nicht mehr nehmen kann ununterbrochen, mal eine Stunde irgendwas zu gucken. Also ich mach das immer so, dass ich einfach Sachen abklemmen muss, damit ich in der Lage bin, mich mit irgendwas zu beschäftigen. Da muss ich dann auch tatsächlich mal einen Tag nicht erreichbar sein. Und zwar auch nicht am Telefon. Und ich kann also auch nur warnen vor diesen ganzen Chat- und Slack-Geschichten, die da gerade, und wie heißt das, Microsoft Teams, jeder versucht jetzt in diesem Markt irgendwie die Leute daran zu hindern, sich mal zehn Minuten am Stück zu konzentrieren. Das hat bei mir auch, hab ich beobachtet, die Art des Zugangs zu Problemen geändert. Also ich bin immer noch gerne bereit, mich immer drei Stunden über ein YouTube-Video irgendwo einzuarbeiten. Aber dann muss ich vorher wissen, dass es einen Payoff geben wird. Also diese explorative Geschichte findet bei mir auf YouTube eher selten statt.
Ja, eigentlich kann ich so nicht sagen. Also hängt vom Thema ab. Wenn ich halt irgendwas wissen, also was ich gerne gerne mache auf YouTube, sind Vorträge gucken. Also von Leuten, die halt einfach ihre Uni-Vorträge oder was auch immer. Da kann es auch ein eher abseitiges Thema sein, wenn der Vortrag oder die Vortragne gut ist.
Da gibt es echt Schätze übrigens.
Ja, viele. Und dann bin ich da auch bereit, halt gerne mal den Autoplay einfach laufen zu lassen. Aber ich finde, dass diesen Punkt, dass man ein Ziel haben muss, um das Gefühl zu haben, Wissen sich effizient anzueignen und auch Willens zu sein, dabei Hürden zu überwinden und halt irgendwie mal zu gucken, was denn jetzt... Zum Teil ist das Problem, dass du findest halt Sachen nicht, weil du nicht weißt, was der richtige Searchterm ist, um den, also teilweise sind es ja so Bindialekte, die sich dann in so Communitys bilden. Also wo du halt irgendwie keine Ahnung hast, wie denn jetzt dieses Teil heißt oder diese Arbeitsweise heißt, weil das halt irgendwie entweder ein historisches Wort ist oder ein Slangterm, der sich halt in irgendeiner Internetkommunikation gebildet hat. Aber trotzdem bist du dann irgendwann bereit zu sagen, okay, mach ich, guck mir an, will ich wissen. So, und wenn du halt ungefähr den Aufwand abschätzen kannst. Dieses Problem mit irgendwie der ständigen Ablenkung.
Du musst aber angefixt sein.
Genau, du musst eine Motivation haben. Du musst es wollen. Das ist halt glaube ich genau der Punkt.
Du brauchst Priming.
Na, du brauchst ein Ziel, du brauchst einen, also du brauchst eine...
Das stimmt bei mir nicht, ich brauch kein Ziel. Also ich kann mir auch stundenlang mit dem Ziel des Wissensgewinns Sachen angucken. Also wenn zum Beispiel eine Konferenz gibt, von der ich weiß, dass die Qualität der Vorträge im Allgemeinen gut ist, dann mach ich auch exploratives YouTube'n und gucke mir in Ruhe irgendwelche. Klar. Aber ich glaube, man muss halt vorher sozusagen, also man ist jetzt Teil von einer Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie und man muss vorher sozusagen Gründe für die Annahme haben, dass es einen Payoff gibt inzwischen. Weil es einfach zu viele andere Schranken, freie, barrierelos, zugreifbare, nicht nur Unterhaltungen, sondern auch anderes Wissen gibt. Ja. Aber das ist überhaupt eine interessante Frage. Inwieweit konkurriert eigentlich Wissen an der Stelle mit Entertainment?
Dauernd, die ganze Zeit.
Ist es so, dass das Entertainment immer mehr wird und das Wissen wegschwemmt, so von der Zeit, die wir zu investieren bereits sind?
Wir haben, glaube ich, den Anspruch, dass uns das Wissen Entertainment präsentiert wird.
Das ist doch eigentlich absurd, oder?
Nö. Finde ich nicht. Weil am Ende ist leichte Aufnehmbarkeit von Wissen und eine Präsentation, die dich ein bisschen bei der Stange hält, schon immer das Kennzeichen von guter Wissensvermittlung gewesen.
Naja, aber das ist ja jetzt ein anderer Moment. Also, Entertaining und bei der Stange halten, ist eine andere Anforderung, finde ich.
Das aber kommt dasselbe hinaus. Nämlich, dass du halt annimmst, dass dein Publikum auch noch was anderes zu tun hat. Das ist halt die dem zugrunde liegende Annahme.
Das ist natürlich immer gut, aber das Problem ist halt, dass es ein zweiter Skill-Set ist. Das heißt, wenn du sagst, ich gucke mir nur Wissensvermittlung an, wenn die interessant vorgetragen wird, verlierst du möglicherweise den Ultraspezialisten, der nie...
Klar, den brauchst du meistens, aber auch nur, wenn du wirklich wissen willst, wenn du ein Ziel hast. Also wenn du halt wirklich wissen willst, wie keine Ahnung halt irgendwie was wirklich passiert, wenn zwei schwarze Löcher kollidieren und dir halt irgendwie die Computer-Animation von Neule Grasse nicht mehr reicht, dann wirst du halt im Zweifel dir auch das Paper von diesem Spezialisten oder dieser Spezialistin ausbuddeln und wirst versuchen, die irgendwie nicht ganz unkomplizierte Mathe darin zu verstehen. Und wenn du es wirklich wissen willst, dann gehst du halt los und holst dir irgendwie den Vortran-Code aus dem Archiv.
Von der NASA, von den Backup-Tapes.
Nee, die machen heute noch einen Vortran-Code.
Aber hast du das nicht mitgekriegt, dass es dieses Projekt gab aus den Freiwilligen, die aus den alten Tapes, für die es keine Lesegeräte mehr gab, die Backups irgendwie manuell rausgekratzt haben?
Von den Mondbildern. Aber der Aufwand, den du da reinsteckst, hängt halt von deiner Motivation ab. Und wenn du bei random browsing plötzlich über Motivation stolperst, dann go for it. Also ich meine, klar, natürlich. Weil es gibt nichts Schöneres.
Ja, also gut. Wie kriegen wir das denn hin, dass es für mich als Informationskonsumenten erkennbar ist, wie viel Abdeckung ich habe? Das ist doch eigentlich mein Hauptproblem. Ja, dass ich mir irgendwie, sag mal, fünf Videos und zehn Papers angucke.
Du kennst doch diese aus dem Anhalter, wo sofort Bibel-Brocks in den allwissenden Durchblicksstrudel steigt. Und dieser allwissende Durchblicksstrudel zeigt einem das gesamte Universum, das gesamte große Universum mit einem winzig kleinen Pfeil, das deine Position in diesem Universum markiert. Du bist hier. Das ist tatsächlich immer die vollständig gültige Darstellung von, wie du in der Relation zu allem Wissen stehst.
Ja, super. Wie so ein Mathematikerwitz, oder? Du musst Mathematiker sein. Die Antwort war komplett richtig, aber nicht weiterhelfend.
Also die Frage ist, ist dein Wissen hinreichend vollständig? War es schon früher schwierig zu beantworten, weil du natürlich nicht nur abstraktes Wissen hast, sondern auch irgendwie Fertigkeiten?
Ich glaube, das war der eigentliche Mehrwert von so Directories wie Yawu oder in der Bibliothek der Zettelkasten ist gar nicht, dass du deinen Scheiß findest.
Sondern, dass du die Illusion von Vollständigkeit gehabt hast.
Genau, dass du das Gefühl hast, okay, also alles, wo dieses Stichwort vorkommt, jetzt hab ich die auch alle abgedeckt. Und das kriegst du halt im YouTube-Zeitalter nicht mehr, das Gefühl, weil es immer diese unendlich nach unten screubbaren See-all-so-Listen gibt, die einfach nie aufhören.
Letzter Endes, wenn du in die Akademie guckst, dann hast du so unterschiedliche Anforderungen an die akademischen Grade. Und so jetzt mal völlig unzulässig vorallgemeinand und irgendwie schlagt mich nicht zusammengefasst, kann man ja sagen, dass du so ein Master ist halt die, also wenn du eine Masterarbeit schreibst, dann musst du darlegen können, dass du in die winzigen Fizzle-Wissensgebiet, was du da gerade ausgesucht hast, innerhalb deines großen Wissengebietes, einen vollständigen Überblick über den State of the Art hast. Na, so dass du halt weißt, was da the thing ist und irgendwie alle wesentlichen Papiere dazu gefunden hast und irgendwie alle wesentlichen Bücher dazu gelesen, durchgearbeitet und kompakt dargestellt hast. Die Anforderung an einen Master. Die Anforderung an einen Doktor ist, also in den ernsthaften Naturwissenschaften, also jetzt mal abgesehen von sowas wie Jura oder so, ist ja, dass du was Neues hast. Also dass du tatsächlich was Neues entwickelst. Also dass du eine neue Erkenntnis hast, dass du eine neue Theorie hast. Ja, gut, ich idealisiere jetzt gerade ein bisschen. Also dass du halt eine neue Theorie hast. Und deshalb glaube ich, so ein ganz guter Anhaltspunkt, dass du die Frage ist halt, auf welches Level willst du denn an einem Wissensgebiet kommen? Willst du halt irgendwie, reicht es dir, wenn du halt so ein Bachelor Lehrlingswissen hast? Heißt du bist Practitioner? Das heißt, du kannst dich in dem Gebiet so halbwegs bewegen, weißt ungefähr, wo vorne ist, kennst die wesentlichen Sachen und kannst damit arbeiten? Willst du ein Master werden? Das heißt, du kennst dich in einem schmalen, also das ist ja so eine Pyramide, die nach unten zeigt. Kennst du dich in dem ganz schmalen Teil dieser Pyramide unten noch aus? Weißt, kennst alle wesentlichen Player? Hast du zu dem bestimmten Zeitpunkt irgendwie alles Wissen, was es dazu Wissen gab, gefunden?
Ich finde das aber zwei Dimensionen, die nicht unbedingt dasselbe bedeuten. Also es gibt einfach Fälle, da ist mir das völlig ausreichend, wenn ich einen sozusagen Comic-Sans irgendwie Überblick habe. Aber ich möchte dann wissen, dass der Überblick zumindest grob die Karte abdeckt und nicht nur irgendwie Südbrandenburg, weißt du? So, also wie tief das geht, ist eine Dimension, aber wie breit es geht, ist die zweite Dimension. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das dasselbe ist. Und mir würde es eigentlich in den meisten Fällen schon reichen, wenn ich wüsste, dass die Breite da ist. Ja, also weil das Gefühl tatsächlich komplett durchgestiegen zu sein, das habe ich sowieso selten. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch gut so. Aber ich möchte zumindest das Gefühl haben, dass es nicht da noch einen Ozean und einen zweiten Kontinent gibt, von dem ich nichts wusste. So, das ist eigentlich eine Sache, die ich fast wichtiger finde, als wie tief du vorgedrungen bist. Und das finde ich halt sehr schwierig zu erkennen.
Na, das hängt halt immer von deinem Anwendungszweck ab. Ich meine, also letzten Endes entwickeln wir uns ja, wenn wir es drauf anlegen und uns nicht von der Welt isolieren und alles viel zu kompliziert und schwierig finden, eher in die Richtung von Generalisten, die trotzdem in der Lage sind, in einzelnen Gebieten Spezialistenwissen zu haben. Das ist ja eigentlich so das Ideal, was man so von sich hat. So, dass man halt so quasi so ein...
Man kann überall mitreden.
Wenn du ein polytechnisches Wissen hast, dann ist das, finde ich, das Ideal dieser polytechnischen Bildung immer noch irgendwie gut, nämlich zu sagen, okay, also war halt auch die DDR-Bildung strukturiert auf der naturwissenschaftlichen Ebene, zu sagen, du hast von allem im Wesentlichen schon mal das Mindeste erklärt bekommen und weißt Bescheid, kannst du es einordnen. Und wenn du nicht auf irgendwas spezialisierst, weißt du, wo diese Spezialisierung im Kontext zum Rest der Welt ist. Und das wird natürlich immer schwieriger, weil die Welt halt größer wird und es viel mehr zu verstehen gibt und viel mehr auch menschengeschaffene Strukturen gibt, deren Verständnis immer schwieriger wird und deren Komplexität halt immer größer wird. Und diese die Einordnungskompetenz, also wo sind die denn, also wo gehört denn dieses Puzzlestück jetzt eigentlich hin? Deswiderum wird halt einfacher gemacht durch eine ideologische Betrachtung.
Na ja, es ist ja nicht wirklich einfacher, es fühlt sich nur einfach an.
Ja, reicht ja. Na ja, reicht der letztendlich, weißt du?
Du fieser Zyniker.
Na ja, passt doch so, ne? Na ja, also ich glaube...
Weißt du, ich hab immer noch dieses antike Ideal, der irgendwie zumindest, dass der Versuch zumindest gültig ist, etwas objektiv zu betrachten, auch wenn es nicht gelingen wird. Und da würde ich mich echt ungern von trennen, sodass ich das nicht mal versuchen kann.
Natürlich ist der Versuch ehrenwert, und wir sollten ihn noch nicht aufgeben. Weil sonst, also wenn wir sagen, wir geben auf und sagen wir betrachten die Welt nur noch aus unterschiedlichen ideologischen Perspektiven, dann haben wir halt schon verloren.
Aber so ist es doch im Wesentlichen, oder?
Na, die Tendenz geht halt da hin, und zwar aus dem Grund, weil die, ähm, sag mal, der, das rein objektive zerfragen der Welt hat nicht dazu geführt, dass was Neues entstanden ist. Und, muss man einfach mal so konstatieren. Na, also tatsächlich die... Naja, auf der einen Weise schon, oder?
Zum Beispiel?
Naja, wo ist die Physik heute?
Na, also, das ist ja nun eine andere Diskussion.
Nein, das ist genau...
Ob du findest, dass es schnell genug voran geht.
Das ist genau die Diskussion. Das ist halt irgendwie... Natürlich, meine Gute, in der Wissenschaft ist es einfacher. Da kannst du halt ein Theorie-Gebäude abreißen und dann erst mal weiter damit leben, dass es kein neues gibt. Das ist jetzt nicht so tragisch. So ist halt ein bisschen blöd für die Karrieren von ein paar Leuten, aber es ist jetzt irgendwie keine große Tragik. Im Rest der Welt, außerhalb von so hardcore Grundlagenwissenschaften, ist die Situation ein bisschen schwieriger, weil wenn du da halt politische Ökonomie nimmst, so was wir da gelernt haben, ist immer alles zu hinterfragen. Die zentrale Funktion.
Die konstruieren.
Ja, klar. Das ist genau das, wo die Struktur der Welt, wie wir sie heute haben, herkommt. Das ist der normale Modus operandi war. Nichts mehr glauben, keine Autoritäten anerkennen, alle Machtstrukturen hinterfragen, alle Interessenkonflikte zu hinterfragen, persönliches Verhalten zu hinterfragen und so weiter und so fort.
Und jetzt sind wir alle Zyniker, die in der Ecke sitzen und keiner kommt voran.
Genau, der Impuls ist ja im Prinzip richtig. Natürlich willst du halt irgendwie wissen, warum jemand irgendwas macht. Also du willst dich nicht verarschen lassen. Du willst halt nicht, dass eine Studie, die von Monsanto finanziert und gesponsert wird, am Ende sagt halt irgendwie, dieses oder jenes Insektizid ist total super, deswegen können wir es halt genehmigen. Und du hast nicht hingeguckt und nicht gesagt, hier Entschuldigung, warum Monsanto diese Studie bezahlt haben, die können wir vielleicht nicht ernst nehmen. So blöd willst du eigentlich nicht sein. Auf der anderen Seite ist aber dieses nicht aufhören können zu hinterfragen, führt dann halt irgendwie zu so einer Eskalation auch von regulatorischem Druck. Also dieses Beispiel zum Beispiel mit den Lebensmitteln. Also wir wissen halt bei vielen von diesen irgendwie Schadstoffen, die da in Nanogramm-Dingern unterwegs sind, wissen gar nicht, ob die überhaupt eigentlich etwas bewirken. Es gibt keine Statistiken dazu. Also offensichtlich kann viel von dem Zeug auch so tödlich nicht gewesen sein. Also die Fälle...
Der Bauer nicht kennt, das ist ja nicht...
Also ich finde ganz ehrlich, auch ein großer Teil dieser Feinstaubdiskussionen sind halt irgendwie fallen halt in so eine Richtung, wo man einfach sagen muss, okay, wir wissen das jetzt nicht so geil. Die Orteindustrie hat uns halt verarscht, das war halt auch nicht so gut. Aber...
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir Leute, die 90 werden, wenn der Feinstaub da draußen uns alle umbringen würde.
Also wie viel Prozent, also wenn man es mal hochrechnet, wie viel Prozent Lebenszeit kriegt man denn dazu? Also wie viel Prozent leidensfreie Lebenszeit, das etwa zählt? So und was wird die Auswirkung davon? Das können wir gar nicht beantworten, wissen wir nicht. Das ist ein großes Experiment. Vielleicht ist es geil, vielleicht werden wir alle zehn Jahre älter, wenn sie den Feinstaub abgeschafft haben. Was ich nicht glaube, weil der Großteil des Feinstaubs kommt vom Abrieb von Autoreifen, da redet niemand drüber, sondern nur über ein bisschen Diesel. Oder niemand redet auch über, außer Kachelmann redet halt irgendwie über den Feinstaub aus den Luxus-Kaminen, in den Gentrifizanten-Siedlungen so. Interessiert offensichtlich ja niemanden so. Aber so eine Diskussion, die halt aus so einer ideologischen Perspektive geführt werden, führen halt dazu, dass die Legitimität von regulatorischen Aktivitäten hinterher einfach schrumpft.
Aber das ist doch dasselbe Phänomen, was ich vorhin angesprochen habe, dass die Leute denken, Umweltschutz ist eine Sache, da kann ich was machen. Auto fahren, das ist eine Entscheidung, die kann ich treffen. Fahre ich jetzt Diesel oder nicht, aber das gentrifizierte Viertel mit den Kaminen, da kann ich auch nur irgendwie impotent die Faust drücken. Deswegen ist das, machst du mir sozusagen mein schönes Narrativ kaputt, wenn du anfängst da jetzt irgendwie von anderen Sachen zu reden. Insofern ist das, glaube ich, eine natürliche Abwehrreaktion auch auf die steigende Komplexität der Welt, dass ich mir den Teil raussuche, bei dem ich glaube, ich habe noch Agency. Und da versuche ich dann halt irgendwas zu tun.
Klar, ich meine, die Frage nach, wie schaffst du es halt in deinem eigenen Leben, Selbstwirksamkeit hinzubekommen?
Komplexitätsreduktion.
Genau. Und dann nimmst du dir halt, pickst dir halt irgendwas raus und kümmerst dich dann halt halt um. Das ist ja genau das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, such dir halt ein Ziel. Und das kann, wenn du das falsche Ziel wählst oder ein Ziel wählst, was halt irgendwie jetzt, sagen wir mal, deren Wirksamkeit so ein bisschen eingeschränkt ist, dann ist es, naja, dann kannst du dir halt die Frage stellen, ändere ich jetzt das Richtige gemacht, ändere ich jetzt irgendwie meine Verhaltensweise, das geht nicht. Also mein Lieblingsbeispiel sind halt so vielfliegende Veganer. Ja, wie die dann mit CO2 argumentieren. So, wo ich dann irgendwie...
Wie ich dachte, Veganer argumentieren mit, das ist irgendwie, das sind Lebewesen, die haben genau so ein Recht zu leben.
Die neueren Argumentationen...
Ist auch mit CO2?
Ist auch mit CO2. So und das ist halt, also ich meine, wenn sie mit dem Recht auf Lebewesen argumentieren, kann ich das verstehen. Das ist halt irgendwie eine vollständig volide Argumentation, der man auch einfach aus ethisch-moralischen Gründen wenig entgegensetzen kann. So, aber wenn sie dann anfangen, mit CO2 zu argumentieren, dann finde ich das halt einfach nur lächerlich, ja, so weil das halt irgendwie...
Naja, also da, das, ich weiß nicht, also ich reibe mich auch gerne an solchen Leuten, aber auf der anderen Seite verstehe ich immer nicht, das macht doch das Argument nicht weniger valide, wenn der Typ ein Heuchler ist, der es vorträgt.
Nee, macht nicht weniger valide.
So, dass wir sind halt von Heuchlern umgeben, das finde ich aber nicht schlimm. Menschen sind halt Heuchler.
Das Schlimme daran finde ich halt nur, wenn Menschen...
Dieses Gefühl, dass die irgendwie von sich selbst glauben, jetzt den Heiligen Krieg zu führen und im Recht zu sein.
Können sie ja gerne machen, solange sie mich noch nicht belästigen. Das Problem ist, mein Problem dabei sind halt missionierende Ideologen.
Ja, also das kann ich jetzt persönlich auch nicht mit umgehen, aber das heißt nicht, dass ihre Argumente irgendwie scheiße sind, nur weil ich den Typ nicht mag und weil der ein Idiot ist und ein Heuchler. Also ich weiß, das ärgert mich momentan so ein bisschen daran, es gibt halt irgendwie so eine ganze Batterie aus irgendwelchen rechten Blogs und Twitter-Leuten, die irgendwie die Greta Thunberg anpinkeln, weil ja irgendjemand irgendwie mit einem Motorboot mitgefahren ist und da hätte sie ja dann doch CO2. Und da denk ich mir so, ja und, wen interessiert denn das? Ja, das ändert doch nichts an der Situation. Ob jetzt Greta Thunberg CO2 ausstößt oder nicht.
Na ja, das ist halt aus einer reinen Propagandaperspektive.
Ja, tolle Propaganda, aber mehr halt auch nicht.
Nee, es ist halt das Problem, dass sie, dass in dem Umblick, wo du dich halt auf ein sehr hohes Podest stellst, also sozusagen der Heiligen Schein sehr groß ist, ist natürlich die Versuchung genau da, in den Wein zu pinkeln halt relativ groß. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, wo man einfach sagen muss, das war halt einfach ein handwerklicher Fehler. Tut mir leid. Also halt da so ein Zinnober drum zu machen, das jetzt mit einem Segelboot über den Atlantik fährt, war eine Einladung dafür, da nach irgendwas zu suchen, woran man rummekeln kann. Das war halt so ein...
Ja, aber das kannst du doch gar nicht den Leuten recht machen. Das geht doch gar nicht.
Nee, na gut, jemand, der das machen kann, steigt einfach in ein Flugzeug, pflegt darüber wie alle anderen auch, pflanzt dreimal so viele Bäume, wie sie CO2 verbraten hat und fertig. Da hätte niemand drüber geredet.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich finde auch nicht, dass sie da irgendetwas schuldig ist, ehrlich gesagt. Sie hat sich ja nicht auf das Podest gestellt. Sie ist darauf gestellt worden, weil sie halt sich toll geeignet hat, als irgendwie die jungfrau von Orléans, die unseren Drachen tötet.
Ich bin extrem immer noch fasziniert davon, dass sie es halt schafft, wirklich so viele Menschen zu bewegen, ihr eigenes Leben zu überdenken und ihre eigenen Prioritäten zu überdenken und einen neuen, naja, also mal positiv formuliert, ein neues Glaubensideal im Sinne von einer übergreifenden Priorität für die Einordnung des eigenen Lebens zu schaffen, für einen guten Zweck. So, das ist halt eine Sache, wo ich immer noch extrem fasziniert bin, dass das funktioniert. Dass die natürlich ist halt von den Leuten, die halt irgendwie keinen Bock darauf haben, ihr Leben zu ändern und die halt irgendwie weiter gerne halt irgendwie ihre 15 Liter Benzin auf 100 Kilometer irgendwie SUVs durch die Gegend fahren wollen, dass die sich dann halt an so einem kleinen Scheiß aufhängen, ist natürlich vollkommen klar.
Die haben halt nichts anderes.
Die nehmen halt was immer geht, so weil die natürlich, also aber am Ende ist...
Ja, aber weißt du, ich finde, das sagt mehr über die Leute als über Geräte aus. Ich lach mal nur, wenn ich sowas hier und denk mir, so was wollt ihr denn hier, gesagt ihr nicht, wie scheiße das aussieht.
Was ich halt nur sage, ist halt aus meiner Perspektive, als jemand, der halt das Handwerk der Propaganda mit großem Interesse verfolgt, muss man da einfach sagen, hat sie da einen handwerklichen Fehler gemacht. Mehr sag ich nicht. Also sie kann das Segelboot fahren, so viel wie sie will, ist mir völlig egal. Sie könnte von mir aus sich irgendwie in einem Zeppelin darüber fliegen lassen.
Aber wieso ist denn es ihre Schuld, wenn ein Reporter mitfährt? Den hat sie ja nicht eingeladen.
Nein, das ist ja nicht ihre Schuld. Ich sag nur, sie hat handwerklich Fehler gemacht.
Nein, aber ich meine, was hätte sie denn tun können? Das ist doch blöd.
Sie hätte diese Segelbootnummer einfach streichen können.
Das fand ich in Ordnung mit dem Segelboot.
In dem Umblick, wo du sagst, ich fahre mit dem Segelboot, um CO2 anzusparen, machst du dich natürlich angreifbar dafür, dass jemand nicht aufhört zu fragen, wie kommt denn die Crew dahin? Was ist dann noch für ein Boot mitgefahren? Sind die wirklich die ganze Zeit gesegelt?
Ja, aber das ist doch alles nicht in ihrem Kontrollbereich. Wieso kann man ihr das nicht vorwerfen?
Natürlich ist es nicht in ihrem Kontrollbereich, aber es ist dann in dem Umblick ein einfacher Hebel, um ihre eigenen Messen zu bestellen.
Ich verstehe, dass das irgendwie für die Propaganda nicht toll war, aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass sie das für die Propaganda gemacht hat.
Na klar, hat sie das für Propaganda gemacht, sonst wusste ich, warum soll sie das sonst antun.
Weil, ey, als ich 16 war, wenn mir jemand gesagt hätte, hier ist ein Segelboot, wir fahren jetzt...
Fährst du im Herbst über den Atlantik, na schön.
Aber klar hätte ich das gemacht. Na, wie viele Gelegenheiten im Leben hast du, das zu machen? Okay, na hallo hätte ich das gemacht.
Gut, ja.
Wäre ich vielleicht abgesoffen, wäre ich gerade gewesen. Aber hey, das wäre irgendwie so eine Gelegenheit, nimmst du doch mit.
Na gut, also jedenfalls, was mich halt irgendwie daran so nervt, ist halt, dass die beide Seiten in diesen Konflikten sich so drauf kaprizieren und übrigens wie auch alle bei unseren Politikern und so weiter und so fort, den...
Wie persönliche Verfehlungen nachzuweisen.
Ja, weißt du, das ist halt so eine... Weißt du, das ist halt so diese... Das ist halt einfach, das hat halt so alle Elemente von Puritanertum, weißt du so, also dieses irgendwie, du musst dich perfekt verhalten, immer alles richtig machen, nie das falsche Wort sagen, immer irgendwie darauf achten, dass du auch wirklich irgendwie jeden Kilometer, den du fährst, irgendwie Klima kompensierst, weil sonst bist du irgendwie nicht mehr der Klima-Heilige.
Vor allem lenkt es ja auch davon ab, was du dann für wirklich schlimme Sachen tun, wie jetzt gerade diesen Referentenentwurf, der jetzt hier diese Tage durchs Netz geistert, wo drinsteht, die möchten gerne einmal von den ISPs und Dienste-Providern den entschlüsselten Zugriff haben auf die Daten und Accounts.
Ja, unter dem Stichwort Hasskriminalität.
Genau, für die Bekämpfung des Hasses. Und dann denk ich mir so, äh...
Und bei uns ist es halt auch so ein Ding, wo halt einfach der...
Ja, lass uns darüber reden, ob der CO2-Ausstößt, der Typ, so wat? Ja, das ist überhaupt nicht so... Also, naja, das schräg mich hier wieder auf.
Nee, aber ich glaube schon, das ist wichtig, sich darüber aufzuregen, weil die...
Trinkt der eigentlich die richtigen Fruten? Wie heißt die? Es gab doch diesen... diesen Smoothie-Hersteller, der sich da irgendwie mit seiner Werbung ungeliegt hat. Weil ich mir so dachte so, habt ihr sonst keine Probleme, ja?
Nee.
Lass uns zu überreden, ob der Referentenentwurf von jemandem geschrieben wurde, der Uber benutzt. Weil dann ist das nämlich ein böser Mensch. So. Ja.
Also ich glaube aber, dass die Antwort darauf ist, dass sich in seinem persönlichen Leben mit anderen vergleichen, ist eine Handlung, die Menschen sowieso gerne machen. Und sich dann darüber aufzuregen, dass irgendjemand anders irgendeiner echten oder imaginierten sozialen Norm nicht folgt, ist halt sehr einfach. Das ist halt so ein Impuls, der auch Menschen, die sagen wir mal intellektuell jetzt irgendwie nicht unbedingt Hochlastungssportler sind, nachvollziehen können. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, das ist halt so ein, sich über andere Menschen zu eschöphieren und was die jetzt wieder richtig oder falsch gemacht haben.
Vor allem, wenn die an einer Machtposition dir gegenüber sind.
Ja, selbst wenn sie nicht in einer Machtposition sind.
Ja, aber gerade dann ist es sehr befriedigend, wenn du sagen kannst, der Typ da oben, der ist aber schlechter als ich.
Oder beziehungsweise, wenn du halt den Anspruch daran hast, dass jemand, der zum Beispiel ein politisches Ideal vertritt, dass er diesen sozialen Normen, die zu diesem politischen Ideal gehören, in allen einzelnen Punkten immer hundertprozentig folgt. Das ist ja der Anspruch, den wir als Gesellschaft da irgendwie dran haben.
Meinst du jetzt Salonkommunisten?
Nee, also bleiben wir mal beim Beispiel Klima.
Salonkommunist ist doch der Ursprung von diesem Ding. Du sagst irgendwie, der ist hier für die Sozialisten im Parlament, aber irgendwie geht in den Altherren-Club und trinkt irgendwie den teuren Brandwein und mit den anderen Leuten im teuren Anzug. Irgendwie macht der da elitäre Zigarren rauchen. Das war doch der ursprüngliche Vorschlag. Der zahlt auf Klima.
Meine Sicht darauf ist, dass dieser Vorbildcharakter von Individuen, bzw. dieser Anspruch darin, dass Individuen, die bestimmte Position vertreten, immer der Vorbildcharakter sein müssen für diese Position. Dass wir den vielleicht ein bisschen zurückdrehen. Im Grundsatz finde ich es nicht schlecht, zu sagen, jemand, der bestimmte Prinzipien vertritt, wäre auch gut, wenn er die so ein bisschen lebt. Einfach nur deswegen, damit er auch so ein bisschen Relative-Feedback bekommt darauf, ob diese Positionen überhaupt vertretbar und realistisch sind. Aber daraus einen Absolutheitsanspruch zu machen, finde ich jetzt halt irgendwie einfach völlig daneben. Also vor allen Dingen erledigt sich ja dann damit häufig die politische Debatte, weil man halt eben nur über, was auch immer, darüber redet, wie viel CO2 der Dienstwagen jetzt ausstößt. Also das ist halt so ein, während nebendran, also ich meine, es gab ja gerade die deutsche Umwelthilfe, ist ja immer der Meister darin, irgendwie solche ehrlich gesagt nicht besonders im globalen Kontext relevanten Themen zu wochenlang auf der Agenda zu halten. Also das ist halt irgendwie so, ich muss leider sagen, das ist halt so ein Verein, wo ich immer weniger Sympathie dafür habe, in welcher Art und Weise die agieren, weil die sich halt auf Themen kaprizieren, die halt schlagzahlendträchtig sind. Aber was den Impact angeht, halt ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen wenig Relevanz haben. Und klar kann man jetzt sagen, wenn wir darüber reden, wie viel CO2 die Dienstwagen der deutschen Umweltminister ausstoßen, dann kann man darüber halt den Sackway machen, zu sagen, was denn eigentlich mit den SUVs und warum haben wir jetzt plötzlich eine Million SUVs, die irgendwie neu zugelassen wurden im letzten Jahr. Aber eigentlich reden dann trotzdem alle nur darüber, wie dick die Karre ist, die dieser Arena-Minister fährt.
Naja, ich glaube, das ist schon nicht ungeschickt, weil das ist eben die Frage, die auch die Leute auf der Straße bewegt.
Was die Leute auf der Straße bewegt, sind SUVs.
Nee, das ist, was sie betrifft, was sie bewegt ist.
Nein, bewegt, das, was sie durch die Gegend fährt.
Ach so, meinst du. Ich meine, die Umwelthilfe hat ja auch diese Bonn-Berlin, oder dass das das EU-Parlament immer hin und her zieht. Das ist ja auch eine völlig sinnlose CO2-Produktion.
Passiert das da halt nix, ne?
Nee, natürlich nicht. Aber das fand ich schon wichtig, dass das mal jemand anspricht, dass das völlig sinnlos irgendwie...
Ich fand das ja so was von unwichtig.
Naja, also ich weiß nicht...
Die statistischen Auswirkungen davon sind null.
Naja.
Ja, ist so. Das ist halt, also wenn du dir...
Das ist nicht ganz null.
Aber das ist halt im Bereich des Rundungsrauschens.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich finde man... Also ich hab ja... Naja, sollte mich ja nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber ich bin auch häufig einer von denen, die dann von Leuten fordert, wenn sie anderen gegenüber moralisch indigniert irgendwie Kritikäußerungen vorbringen, dass sie dann auch aber bitte selber nicht denselben Fehler gemacht haben sollten. So, das finde ich schon...
Ich finde moralisch indignierte Kritik immer eigentlich zunehmend falsch.
Ja, das kann man natürlich auch sagen. Aber wenn du sie schon vorbringst, dann solltest du bitte auf einer Position sein, wo die nicht genau so gegen dich zurück schlägt.
Ja, das ist halt das Problem.
Das gibt's halt nicht. Kommt halt nicht vor. Deswegen im Grunde ist die Folgerung dieselbe. Also, kommt denn diese ganze Scheißkomplexität eigentlich her? Da war es ja auch noch eine Theorie, die wir uns eigentlich gerne mal hier verbreitet haben.
Also wir haben ja so eine Welt, die halt immer komplexer wird, weil wir halt einen... Nee, warte mal, ich muss nochmal ganz kurz nochmal zurück. Okay. Der Punkt ist halt, was dieses moralisch gute Verhalten angeht. Dagegen ist überhaupt nichts einzuwenden. Also im Gegenteil ist es so, dass es natürlich vielen Menschen auch einfach Halt gibt, dass sie halt einfach sagen können, mein Handeln auf dieser Welt versucht auch, wenn es der Einfluss nur minimal klein ist, wenn es viele sind, die es machen, viele die sagen, okay, ich will keine Inlandsflüge machen oder ich will möglichst wenig Fleisch essen oder wenn ich mir schon eine Karre kaufe, versuche ich mir eine Karre zu kaufen, die halt möglichst wenig verbraucht, sowohl was die Herstellung als auch den Verbrauch angeht. Ich versuche halt möglichst viel Fahrrad zu fahren und so weiter. Also ich versuche halt irgendwie meinen persönlichen Footprint zu reduzieren. Ist das eine Sache, die aus meiner Sicht eigentlich uneingeschränkt gut ist, weil sie halt dazu führt, das hat möglicherweise gar keinen Einfluss. So, weil halt irgendwie der Verbrauch wirklich sinkt, wenn es viele Leute machen. Es hat für die Menschen den positiven Effekt, dass sie etwas tun und sich dem Ganzen nicht hilflos ausgeliefert fühlen. Auch wenn sie wissen, dass ihr persönlicher, eigener Effekt nicht messbar sein wird. Wenn es viele machen und sie Teil einer Massenbewegung werden, hat es einen Effekt und das ist der gute Teil daran. Also das ist was, wo man sagen kann, du hast für dich persönlich diese Entscheidung getroffen, du versuchst sie so gut, dass es in deinem Alltag geht, mit allen Einschränkungen, mit allen Problemen, die es macht und allen Unschärfen und allem, was an nicht idealen Zuständen einhergeht. Aber du versuchst wenigstens was zu tun.
Ich dachte immer, das geht um die normative Kraft des Fakten.
Moment, warte mal.
Da kommst du gleich hin?
Da kommen wir gleich hin. Wenn jemand für sich individuell diese Entscheidung trifft und sagt, ich werde Veganer oder ich mache keine Inlandsflüge mehr oder was auch immer, oder eine Kombination von allen möglichen Dingen. Habe ich höchsten Respekt vor. Das finde ich eine Sache, die eigentlich unerhänglich gut ist, weil sie sowohl Selbstwirksamkeit erzeugt, als auch möglicherweise einen positiven Effekt haben kann.
Ein so großes Aber, dass du so einen Schattenstoff hast.
So mein Problem entsteht, wenn daraus ein sozialer Druck entsteht auf andere, der einen moralischen Impetus hat. So ein Ich-bin-heiliger-als-du-Ding. Das ist halt so, diese missionierende Ideologen sind halt eigentlich mein Problem dabei. In dem Augenblick, wo Menschen einfach darüber reden, ich mache das so, weil das ist für mich so, und sie erklären mir das einmal, finde ich vollkommen in Ordnung. Ich habe kein Problem damit. Sie müssen mir ihre Welt sich erklärt, ihren Punkt erklärt. Ich kann das einordnen. Ich weiß halt irgendwie, wo ich mein Verhalten ändern kann. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich weiß, jemand ist vegan, und wir gehen zusammen essen, dann suche ich halt natürlich ein Restaurant aus, wo die Person halt auch was ordentliches veganes zu essen findet.
Kannst du auch ein bisschen nachher einfach wegignorieren?
Nein, kannst du nicht. Weil das Problem ist halt irgendwie, kurz mal den Punkt noch mal zu ändern. Ich respektiere persönliche Lebensentscheidungen uneingeschränkt. Wenn jemand sagt, okay, ich lebe jetzt halt so, das ist jetzt mein Ding, was ich halt machen will, kann ich mir halt überlegen, ob mir persönlich das zu lästig ist. Und ich sage, okay, gehen wir der Person halt nicht mehr essen, weil sie nur Rohkost isst, dann tut es mir halt leid, wenn der Laden keinen Salat hat, das kann bald vorkommen. Aber es haben halt so Sachen, die halt im Rahmen sind, wie zum Beispiel, ich esse halt nur noch vegan, find this me, gibt genügend Optionen, kein Stress. So, ne? Das ist halt so. Und außerdem lerne ich auch was neu kennen. Es gibt mittlerweile sogar leckeres veganes Essen, habe ich festgestellt. Womit ich ein Problem habe, ist in dem Augenblick, wo dann so ein Shaming anfängt. Also in dem Augenblick, wo halt jemand dann sagt, so, aber hier. Allerdings nicht unengeschränkt. Weil zum Beispiel, war jetzt irgendwie diese...
Ein bisschen Shaming ist okay?
Naja, also man muss halt einfach klar sagen, dass Shaming im Sinne von Sätzen einer sozialen Norm Gesellschaft verändert. Aber nicht zum besten. Naja, möglicherweise eben schon. Das ist halt nicht wirkungslos. Also halt so, sagen wir mal, zu sagen, okay, es ist halt nicht okay, rassistische Positionen irgendwie in Diskussionen zu äußern. Also offene ethnorassistische Positionen will ich eigentlich nicht in meiner Umgebung haben. Es ist halt so, ich möchte eigentlich nichts mit zu tun haben, ich möchte mit den Leuten nichts zu tun haben, nichts, was ich halt in meinem Leben haben will. Und dass das halt irgendwie so eine Art gesellschaftlicher Konsens geworden ist, finde ich halt erst mal ganz gut. So. Wenn aber, so, und jetzt kann man halt sagen, wo ist jetzt eigentlich die Grenzziehung? Wenn ich, also, weißt du so, also gibt es halt so diesen Punkt so, wenn Leute sich halt so eine richtig dicke Karre kaufen. Also halt so ein irgendwie 2,8 Tonnen SUV, um halt irgendwie ihre Pfandflaschen und irgendwie ihre Kinder zur Schule zu fahren. So. Und die, ich weiß halt, die brauchen halt keinen Geländewagen, weil die haben irgendwie keine schlammigen Grundstückszufahrt, auch nicht keine 20 Meter. Das geht halt nur darum, dass sich irgendjemand da sicherer fühlt, weil er irgendwie in so einem Mutti-Panzer sitzt und halt irgendwie da gerne hoch oben über der Straße sitzt und sich so fühlt, als wäre genug Blech um ihn drum, was in der Regel auch nicht der Fall ist.
Warte mal, das ist doch jetzt so eine der Zweckeiligt-die-Mittel-Abwägung, die du gerade machst, ne?
Nee, warte, die Frage ist halt, also worüber ich nachdenke, das ist kein abgeschlossener Gedanke, ne? Also die Frage ist halt, ist zum Beispiel SUV-Shaming eigentlich okay?
Also ist aber utilitaristisch der Zugang, den du da jetzt aufbaust, oder nicht?
Der Zugang, ja, das ist korrekt, ist ein utilitaristischer Zugang. In dem Sinne von, ist das eine wünschenswerte gesellschaftliche Veränderung, die aus einer sozialen Konvention erwachsen kann. Na, so dass man halt sagt, okay, also ehrlich gesagt, diese Zahl von eine fucking Million SUVs in letztem Jahr zugelassen, mitten in der größten Klimadiskussion, die wir je hatten. Und dann...
Das sind alles Panikkäufe, glaub ich. Das ist wie, wenn irgendwie das Gerücht umgeht, dass Obama den Leuten die Waffen wegnimmt, dann laufen alle nochmal los, weil die das kaufen. Ich glaube, die glauben, das ist ihre letzte Chance, sich nochmal ein SUV zu kaufen. Also mein Problem mit dieser Art von, aber das Shaming ist okay, weil das funktioniert, ja ist halt, dass die nächste Iteration ist halt dein Kies. Irgendwie ein bisschen ankratzen an der Seite, weil du arsch, ja. Und das ist halt echt ein Slippery-Slob, das haben wir schon mehrfach beobachten können. Wenn du einmal sagst, aus der moralischen Überlegenheit meiner Seite, meiner Position heraus, kann ich jetzt dir gegenüber einige Normen verletzen, wird halt nichts Gutes, sondern das geht dann immer nur ganz schnell in den Abgrund.
Ja, also das ist ein wichtiges Argument. Also wie gesagt, ich bin damit mit dem Denken auch nicht fertig, weil letztendlich ist es halt die Frage, wenn wir halt eine nachhaltige Veränderung der Gesellschaft wollen, in Richtung mehr Klimaschutz, dann wird es notwendig sein, dass wir diese Diskussion über welche Einschränkungen im individuellen Leben wollen wir denn als Gesellschaft in Kauf nehmen und mit welchen, noch wichtiger, mit welchem Mechanismus kommen wir zu einem Konsens darüber?
Ich muss gerade an so einen Short denken, was ich mal in Amerika gesehen hab.
Die müssen wir halt führen.
Da stand drauf, für jedes Steak, was du als Veganer nicht isst, esse ich zwei. Diese Leute gibt es halt auch. Und wenn du dann sagst, Genau. Und mein Ansatz ist, wir machen das jetzt als möglichst viel richtig. Das ist halt nicht hinführend. Das ist gut, um so ein Movement entstehen zu lassen. Aber du hast halt immer so ein paar Arschlöcher. Und man muss sich schon fragen, was machst du mit denen?
Also letzten Endes, wo wir hinwollen, ist, dass die Leute freiwillig das Richtige tun.
Ich hab so eine sehr gespaltene Position entwickelt, die eigentlich nicht logisch konsistent ist. Also wenn ich sehe, dass jemand irgendwie von einem Missionar belästigt wird, weil er moralisch verwörfliche Sachen macht, dann gönne ich dem das, aber finde es trotzdem scheiße, dass es passiert ist, weil ich irgendwie mir denke, okay, wenn ich das jetzt gut heiße, wird es nur schlechter. Also es ändert nichts daran, dass ich опoniere, ändert nichts daran, dass ich es dem nicht gönne. Aber es ist halt nicht der richtige Weg, aus meiner Sicht.
Letzterweise hat die Frage, wenn man sagt, okay, eine freie Gesellschaft kann nur existieren, wenn die Menschen in dieser Gesellschaft möglichst viele Dinge wirklich freiwillig tun. Also wenn halt also die Menge an Regeln, die es sich an der Gesellschaft gibt, möglichst klein ist, aus dem Verständnis heraus, dass jede Regel kostet. Weil jede Regel muss halt maintained werden, erzeugt halt irgendwie eine Menge an Stress und Ärger mit irgendwie Nebenwirkungen, Komplexität, die daraus entstehen. Führt dazu, dass wenn die Regelwerke zu komplex werden, nur noch Spezialisten die Regelwerke verstehen können, alle anderen mit so einer unscharfen Apoximation davon arbeiten und so weiter. Das heißt also dieses Verständnis davon, dass Regeln teuer sind und wir versuchen sollten, die Anzahl dieser Regeln möglichst klein zu halten, die halt für unser Zusammenleben notwendig sind. Das ist halt nicht da. Sondern wir leben halt eher in so einer Zeit, wo…
Das würde ich aber bestreiten, das ist auf jeden Fall da. Wir haben seit ich denken kann, verspricht die Politik, die Gesetze zu vereinfachen. Und das ist noch nie passiert, im Gegenteil. Also das ist der Wunsch aller, ist meine Beobachtung, aber es passiert halt nicht. Also der Bürger, weil es eben ein paar Spezialisten an neuralgischen Punkten gibt, die verlieren würden wirtschaftlich. Wenn also die Berater, die die Gesetze schreiben, die haben halt kein Interesse daran, dass es einfacher wird, weil dann braucht man keine Berater mehr. Aber so, dass die Leute wollen das, alle die Politiker wollen es eigentlich alle?
Es ist nicht nur die Berater, die das wollen. Also ganz klar ist, Komplexität erzeugen und Dinge so kompliziert machen, dass sie unübersichtlich werden, ist ein hartes Machtmittel der Politik.
Es gibt eine lustige Story aus Amerika zur Steuergesetzgebung, wo ein Vorschlag war, dass man den Leuten ein vorausgefülltes Formular schickt, wo die Sachen, die wir schon wissen, schon drinstehen, nach dem Motto. Und dagegen oponiert und das verhindert hat am Ende ein Hersteller von Steuersoftware. Ja, es gibt da ein Machtverhältnis. Ich will das nicht bestreiten. Aber ich würde sagen, dass der weite Teil der Bevölkerung das haben will, das halte ich für nicht bestreitbar.
Also ich glaube, dass das versteht.
Wenn du irgendjemand auf der Straße fragst, fändest du es besser, wenn wir weniger Gesetze hätten?
Na ja, man, die Frage ist, die Leute verstehen ja Gesetze unterschiedlich, weil die Gesamtheit der Regeln und Regularien, die wir als eine Gesellschaft haben, sind ja nicht nur die Gesetze. Das sind ja auch die ganzen Verordnungen. Das sind die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen. Das sind irgendwie die gesamten Vertragswerke, die halt irgendwie das Verhältnis zwischen Unternehmen und Staat zum Beispiel regeln und so weiter.
Also da sind ja noch den Medienstaatsvertrag und so.
Genau, also es gibt halt eine Menge an Komplexität, die weit über die Gesetze hinausgeht. Und ganz viel davon sind ja Sachen, wo die Komplexität aus einem schlecht gemachten Gesetz zwar gefolgert, aber sich später entwickelt hat. Nehmen wir zum Beispiel die ganze Hartz-IV-Bürokratie. Ja, da ist es ja so, dass der, die, die...
Na und die Störerhaftung in Wi-Fi und so, das ist ja auch alles nach dem Gesetz gekommen.
Genau, also wo halt einfach die Implementierung dieser, von diesen Regeln in den Gesetzen dazu geführt hat, dass eine irre Anzahl an echt teuren Regeln entstanden ist, und zwar teuer im Sinne von Zeitbedarf, im Sinne von verbrauchter Lebenszeit, die du halt damit zubringen musst, wenn du in diesem System bist oder an ihm teilnimmst, dass du dich damit auseinandersetzen musst, dass du sie verstehen musst oder damit lebst, dass du es nicht tust und sie hinnimmst wie ein Naturgesetz.
Naja, und das vor allem das Risiko dann einpreisen musst. Also mein Eindruck ist ja, dass die Gesetze absichtlich vage geschrieben werden, weil man als Politiker schon auch weiß, dass man die Materie nicht verstanden hat und sich dann hofft, dass das dann schon durch die…
Das glaub ich übrigens nicht.
Das glaubst du nicht? Erzähl mal, was ist deine Theorie?
Also meine Theorie ist tatsächlich, dass der… dieses dem… den Gerichten, die letztgültige Interpretation davon zu überlassen, ist eine Methode der Risikokompensation. Weil was sie da nämlich tun, ist zu sagen, okay, wir haben für die Politiker… Für die Politiker.
Ja, ja, das mein ich ja. Das war ja meine These.
Okay, dann meinen wir dasselbe. Aber ich glaube, die kommt halt nicht nur aus dem… der Eigenerkenntnis des mangelnden Verstehens der Sachmaterie, sondern als aus der Erkenntnis, dass die Sachmaterie möglicherweise mutiert und dass die Regeln, die daraus entstehen, also die sozusagen das Gesetz betreiben, die Verordnungen und so weiter, dass die halt sich ja auch verändern müssen können dürfen. Weil die, wenn du das alles im Gesetz schon regeln wollen wirst, bis du im Gesetz durch den Bundestag geht, das dauert ja mindestens zwei Jahre.
Das glaube ich aber nicht, weil die, wir haben so viele Nachkorrekturen vom Gesetz.
Oder warte, vielleicht ist es anders. Vielleicht haben die auch einfach nur verstanden, wie die Chinesen regieren.
Ich dachte immer, das ist erst covering als erstes. Als Politiker, wenn du schon ein schlechtes Gesetz machen willst, dann muss aber der Punkt, wo es geplatzt ist, ein Richter gewesen sein. Weil dann kannst du sagen, okay, wir sollen nach korrigieren, weil die Richter hier frei drehen.
Die Chinesen machen das ja anders. Also bei den Chinesen ist es ja so, dass die, auf einmal machen sie vielleicht genauso gleich. Vielleicht ist ja eine andere Ausbringung davon. Bei den Chinesen ist es ja so, dass die, wenn das Politbüro eine neue Direktive rausgibt, und also eine neue politische Richtung, also man denkt ja immer, China ist so eine super zentral gesteuerte Angelegenheit, dann ist diese Direktive eine grobe Richtung. Dann ist die so eine, wir brauchen hier mehr kulturelle Kohärenz. Und die Interpretation, also absichtlich vages Beispiel, die Interpretation dann auf der Basis von irgendwie Provinzregierungen, lokalen Parteieninstitutionen und so weiter und so fort, die kann relativ breit auseinanderlaufen innerhalb von China. Deswegen gibt es dann auch durchaus regionale Unterschiede in wie einzelne Direktiven umgesetzt werden. Und dann gucken die sich das aber auch an.
Das klingt wie diese Bundestagsrede von L'Oréal.
Wie welche Interpretation der Direktive jetzt am erfolgreichsten zu sein scheint.
Und das ist dann die offizielle Interpretation.
Und rollen die dann aus, oder ist das dann die offizielle Interpretation? Deswegen zum Beispiel auch diese Belts and Roads Geschichten, also wo die halt diese infrastrukturgürtel da bauen. Das ist halt nicht alles unbedingt zentral bis zum letzten Bahnhof runtergeplant, sondern da gibt es dann halt so eine Direktive.
Wir werden jetzt das Richtige für das Land tun.
Na ja, ist ein bisschen spezifisch. Das ist dann so, wie wir brauchen in dem Korridor, hier brauchen wir mehr infrastruktur, um halt irgendwie mehr Züge da durchzukriegen. Und dann rüttelt sich das dann aber in den Verhandlungen zwischen den Regierungen und den Banken und den Kritikgebern und so weiter und sofort zurecht und den Leuten, die diese infrastruktur bauen und betreiben, was dann da am Ende rauskommt. Das heißt, es gibt halt mehr so eine, so eine Governance auf strategischer Ebene, was denn von den lokalen Gliederungen der Partei, also die Partei hat immer noch den kompletten Durchgriff, in das eigentliche Doing umgesetzt wird. Und möglicherweise ist das ja bei unseren Politikern mittlerweile so ähnlich, dass die halt eher so nur so diese...
Aber den Durchgriff haben die doch gar nicht. Also der zentrale Punkt fehlt doch dabei.
Nee, die haben den Durchgriff nicht, aber die haben ja die Gerichte dafür, die es dann umsetzen müssen.
Ja, aber die können sie ja nicht kontrollieren.
Ja, vielleicht müssen sie das ja auch nicht kontrollieren. Also ich meine, am wichtigsten ist eigentlich nur, dass irgendwie die Leute davon profitieren sollen, am Ende profitieren. Das ist eigentlich der wesentliche Teil dabei.
Und dass du sagen kannst, du hast was gemacht. Das habe ich immer als den wichtigen Teil empfunden, dass die Politiker gerne sagen möchten, ja, wir haben uns doch um Wi-Fi gekümmert.
Das eine hängt durchaus mit dem anderen zusammen. Also ich meine, das ist halt so ein...
Das ist jetzt so ein Ordnung, na, haben wir mal was gemacht.
Die Digitalisierung ist jetzt erfolgreich abgeschlossen. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie mal ein Wi-Fi-E-Satz gemacht, ja. Aber ich glaube, dieser Prozess ist halt auch super anfällig für so regulatory capture, also dafür, dass halt die...
Erklär mal das Konzept.
Konzept regulatory capture heißt, wenn du als Unternehmen, insbesondere wenn du eins in so einer, sagen wir, Oligopol oder Monopol-Stellung bist oder dahin möchtest, dass du dir überlegst, welche Änderungen an Regeln und Gesetzen würden dazu führen, dass deine Position direkt oder indirekt gestärkt wird. Also ein schönes Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel die Riester-Rente. Na, die Riester-Rente ist ein tolles Beispiel davon von regulatory capture, wo die Versicherungsindustrie den Staat benutzt hat. Das heißt, die haben, also insbesondere halt irgendwie so, wie ist dieser Typ, dieser, vergessen, leicht schmierige Haare, nur für Rana.
Ich weiß schon immer, Carsten Maschmeier.
Ja, genau. Der war ja einer der trafenden Figuren, so guter Freund von Gerhard Schröder und so. Und was die ja durchgebracht haben, war ja ein Konzept von einer zusätzlichen Altersvorsorge, die sich primär dadurch auszeichnet, dass die ersten Jahre der Einzahlung dieser Altersvorsorge in die Provision des Versicherungsunternehmens gehen, der diese Altersvorsorge verkauft hat.
Ja, wie das so ist bei Versicherungen.
Und was halt dazu führt, dass am Ende nur unter sehr engen Randbedingungen man sich davon was hat. Und was die halt gemacht haben, ist, die haben halt, ist den Politikern ermöglicht zu sagen, wir haben uns um dieses Problem Altersvorsorge gekümmert. Parallel dazu lief halt die Medien-Company. Ihr müsst unbedingt was für eure Altersvorsorge tun, weil die Rente wird ja sowieso nichts und irgendwie Riesler-Rente ist the thing. Und das war aber jetzt nicht nur irgendwie dieses eine Unternehmen oder diese eine Unternehmensgruppe, die davon profitiert hat, sondern halt alle. Also es war sozusagen ein Fall von Landschaftspflege, wo die große Gießkonde über der gesamten Branche aufgemacht wurde. Aber zufällig war dieses Unternehmen eines der größten der Branche, was wiederum dazu führte, dass es eigentlich allen besser ging in dieser Branche. Also außer den Leuten, die halt ihr Geld da reingesteckt haben. Und das ist halt so ein klassischer Fall von regulatory capture, wo also du dir dafür sorgst, dass eine Politikinitiative so klingt, als hätten die Politiker jetzt endlich mal was getan. Und rein zufällig stellt sich dann erst ein paar Jahre später hinaus, dass irgendwie diese ganze Nummer primär dazu diente, halt irgendwie Geld irgendwie von vielen Taschen in weniger Taschen zu verteilen.
Also es gibt ja da einen schönen Spruch, mit dem sowas gerne in Amerika prototypisch begründet wird. The rising tide lifts all boats.
Jaja, genau.
Also wenn der Meeresspiegel steigt, weil wir überall ein bisschen Geld hingekippt haben, dann hilft es ja allen Booten und nicht nur denen der großen Versicherung, die hier zufällig unser Partner war. Zufällig, ja.
Also ich glaube, dass dieses Problem von Komplexität als Machtmittel, finden wir an vielen Stellen. Wir haben es bei Skandalen. Also erstes Beispiel, das wir schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, der Leuner-Skandal.
Ich finde Machtmittel zu kurz gegriffen. Ich glaube, ein absolut wichtiger, wenn nicht der dominante Aspekt ist, in die Schuld zu sein. Ja, also das ist natürlich bei, gerade bei Leuner ist es ja so, dass man versucht hat, das so komplex zu machen, dass es überhaupt nicht mehr möglich ist, darüber zu reden, was da eigentlich genau passiert ist. Ich glaube, das ist auch bei vielen Gesetzen so, dass man die einfach so macht, dass im Grunde, selbst wenn es der Clusterfuck ist, der Experten von vornherein gesagt haben, dass es sein würde, dass du dann nicht mehr sagen kannst, wer eigentlich Schuld war. Und am besten ist es so komplex, dass du es überhaupt nicht auf so einer Titelseite, einer Zeitung ausführen kannst, was jetzt eigentlich das Problem ist. Das ist aber nicht Macht aus meiner Sicht, sondern das ist Ass-Covering. Weil der einzelne Funktionär hat ja die Macht nicht. Der ist am besten nach vier Jahren wieder weg. Außer du redest jetzt von den Staatssekretären.
Ich glaube schon, dass es ein Machtmittel aus dem einfachen Grunde weil es dir ermöglicht, Dinge zu tun, die du sonst nie tun könntest. Weil im Zweifel, wenn du halt verhinderst, dass du zur Verantwortung gezogen werden kannst, dann steigt dein Handlungsspielraum. Und selbstverständlich ist es ein Machtmittel, weil du kannst halt einfach Dinge machen, die du sonst nicht tun könntest.
Ja, so gesehen, natürlich auch.
Weil du dir halt um die Konsequenz Gedanken machen musstest.
langfristig, das ist auch die Idee bei AskHovering. Da geht es hier halt darum, landfristig deine Position zu erhalten und lieber nichts zu tun, als etwas, was dir auf den Fuß fallen könnte. Und wenn du schon was tun musst, dann aber so irgendwie obfisketen, dass es nicht auf dich zurückfällt.
Außer es geht um Digitalisierung.
Ja, dann das ist natürlich Internet 4.0, sage ich nur.
Tja.
Wir hatten noch, wo wir gerade bei Amerika waren, haben wir hier noch ein Stichwort aufgeschrieben, den Paperwork Reduction Act.
Oh ja, der Paperwork Reduction Act ist einer meiner Lieblinge aus dieser ganzen Serie. Und zwar ist diese Diskussion darüber, dass irgendwie der Staat zu komplex wird und diese Bürokratie zu groß wird ja nicht neu.
Wir müssen jetzt mal Formulare sparen.
Naja, nee, nee, nee. Es geht ja darum, dass die Formulare effizienter sind. Das ging ja nur darum, dass sozusagen dann nicht...
Nee, das Versprechen war weniger Paperwork.
Ja, weniger Paperwork.
Also das heißt aber auch, Formulare, die man nicht braucht, kommen weg.
Nein, nein.
Aber das ist natürlich nicht passiert.
Nein, also die Intention war, dass in den Formularen nur die Daten erfasst werden müssen, die für diesen Vorgang auch wirklich erfasst werden müssen. Deswegen steht bei diesen Formularen unten drauf...
Das ist, naja, lass mich das mal googeln. Mein Verständnis war, dass sie versprochen haben, wir schaffen überflüssige Formulare ab. Und um rauszufinden, welche Formulare überflüssig sind, sagen wir einfach, du darfst nur noch Daten erheben, von denen du nachweisen kannst, was du brauchst. Und es hat dazu geführt, dass aber alle Formulare in der Realität natürlich beibehalten wurden. Und jetzt aber unten drunter steht irgendwie eine wunderbare Formulierung auch so. Da steht dann so was wie, nach dem Paperwork-Reduction-Act, müssen wir dafür schätzen, wie viel Arbeitsaufwand es ist. Wir glauben, dieses Formular auszufüllen dauert drei Minuten. Die Daten werden benötigt und dann irgendeine belanglose Klausel, die man eh nicht prüfen kann, um die Sicherheit der Nation zu garantieren, blablabla. Und dann, wenn sie damit nicht einverstanden sind, können sie sich beschweren bei, und dann ist eine neue Behörde gegründet worden. Dass irgendwie, was weiß ich, das Paperwork Reduction auffüllt oder wie heißt das?
Ja, das Paperwork Reduction auffüllt.
Und da kannst du dich dann beschweren, indem du ein neues Formular ausfüllst. Das heißt, das Gesetz zum Reduzieren der Formulare hat zu mehr Formularen geführt.
Ja, ich würde sagen, dass......
ein Durchschlag der Erfolge.
Genau. Und wäre auch eine schöne Yes-Minister-Folge. Auf jeden Fall. Aber ich glaube halt, dieses Problem mit der Komplexität...
Das beschäftigt uns ja überall.
Das ist ja nicht nur, ist ja nicht nur, also es hat ja...
Es ist auch beim Programmieren das Hauptproblem gerade. Bei Softwareentwicklung.
Ja, und ich glaube, es wird halt auch nicht weggehen, weil...
Und bei Boeing ist ja auch...
Na gut, bei Boeing war es auch schon viel, also...
Ja, aber eben auch... Man hat ja versucht, die zu verstecken hinter mehr Komplexität, ne? Die man aber hinter einer Abstraktionsschicht verbirgt, damit man sie nicht sieht.
Aber ich glaube, dass das Problem eher ist, dass die... Es gibt ein natürliches Wachsum von Komplexität. Einfach deswegen, weil wir jetzt einfach mehr Menschen sind auf dem Planeten, mehr Menschen irgendwie lesen und schreiben können, mehr Menschen irgendwie an Informationsaustausch teilnehmen, neues Wissen generieren, neue Strukturen generieren, darunter tätig sind. Technologiekomplexität wächst. Wir haben Komplexitätsverstärkertechnologien, wie zum Beispiel SAP, ne? Ist halt so ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass halt Komplexitätsverstärkertechnologie, die halt irgendwie dafür sorgt, dass irgendwie alles noch viel komplizierter wird. Und wie war deine Theorie, wenn dein Unternehmen die SAP-Entführung übersteht, dann ist das hinreichend resilient, dass es als Übernahmekandidat lohnt. Wenn es dabei stirbt, ist das wohl vielleicht weg.
Ja, so ähnlich.
Ich glaube halt, dass diese...
Das ist in der Tat ein Nachweis für ordentliche Managementkompetenzen.
Oder genügend tiefe Taschen.
Ja, aber die kommen ja irgendwo her. Die hast du ja nicht zufällig.
Na gut, auch nicht.
Außer du verbrennst so Tesla-mäßig einfach Investorenkohle oder übermäßig.
Geht ja auch. Aber diese Frage, wie gehen wir mit Komplexität um? Sowohl in unserem Alltag als auch in der Politik als auch in der Technologie ist ja auch nicht neu. Also ist ja so ein Ding, wo halt schon eigentlich seit den 50ern, 60ern des vorigen Jahrhunderts eine Menge Leute drüber nachgedacht haben. Also diese ganzen Systemtheorie und auch viele Bereiche der Management-Theorie, die da ausprobiert wurden, drehten sich ja genau darum. Also wie heißt das? Wissensmanagement und so. Da gibt es ja eine ganze Reihe von...
Eigentlich Sternchen-Management....
von Fachgebieten, die versprochen haben, sich um einzelne Aspekte dieses Komplexitätsproblems zu kümmern.
Am Ende waren sie ähnlich erfolgreich, wie der Paperwork-Reduction erhebt.
Naja, das stimmt.
Wir haben jetzt neue Management-Disziplin.
Es stimmt ja nicht.
Wir haben ein paar wichtige Hashtags gesetzt.
Ich meine, es stimmt ja offensichtlich nicht ganz, weil es gibt offensichtlich, möglicherweise nicht reproduzierbar, aber es gibt offensichtlich zumindest Erfolge dabei. Also wenn du zum Beispiel SpaceX anguckst. SpaceX schafft Dinge innerhalb von Jahren, die die NASA in Jahrzehnten nicht mehr geschafft hat.
Ja, weil die haben halt nur angefangen. Die haben ja nichts genommen und reduziert. Die haben einen neuen Prozess gebaut.
Na die haben nicht nur einen neuen Prozess gebaut, sondern der wichtigste Bestandteil dieses Prozesses ist, dass jeder belohnt wird, der einen Teil aus dem System rausdesignt. Also das ist halt so, das hat halt irgendwie, muss man einfach sagen, Elon Musk, nochmal dieses, das ist halt de facto das Kalashnikov-Prinzip. Also so eine Kalashnikov.
Hat keine beweglichen Teile, die nicht da sein müssen.
Hat halt genauso viele Teile wie unbedingt zwingend da sein müssen und die haben, versuchen immer noch welche wegzulassen, wenn es irgendwie geht oder anders zu machen, um halt die Anzahl der Teile zu reduzieren. Und der baut halt seine Spaceships halt wie Kalashnikovs. Na, sind die man halt sagt, der will halt möglichst wenig Teile haben, weil ihm klar ist, dass die teure Kosten sind halt Komplexität. Und ich glaube, der ist da so ein bisschen der Vorreiter. Na, so weil, also weil, gut, man kann gegen ihn alle möglichen Dinge sagen, aber klar ist halt, dass er dieses Prinzip popularisiert und so sagt, lass uns mal möglichst einfach bauen. Weniger Teile sind weniger Teile, die kaputt gehen können.
Ja, aber guck mal, das erzählen die doch auch seit Jahrzehnten. Ich sag mal, Lean Management, seit wie viel, alles muss einfacher werden und das passiert nie. Sondern da wird dann ein neues Office gegründet, was sich darum kümmert, Sachen einfacher zu machen.
Six Sigma Lean Management Office.
Genau. Und das ist doch, aber ich glaube, der Trick ist, dass du neu anfangen musst. Du musst einfach wegschmeißen. Und dadurch, dass du beim Neuanfang das Problem besser kennst, was du vorher noch nicht kanntest, kannst du auf die Teile verzichten, von denen sich herausgestellt hat, dass du sie nicht brauchst. Aber es war nicht offensichtlich.
Das hilft auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, es gibt aber noch ein Problem dabei, nämlich dass die Unternehmen inzwischen auch eine soziale Komponente haben. Einfach du kannst ja die binden Personal, was sonst arbeitslos wäre. Das heißt, das ist gar nicht gewünscht, Volkswirtschaften die ganzen Leute rauszubeißen.
Das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht. Jedes große Unternehmen, was ich kenne, hat mindestens alle drei Jahre eine Re-Org.
Ja, aber da fliegen keine Leute raus.
Doch, mit dem Versprechen, dass sie Leute rausschmeißen und die Strukturen simplifizieren. Das ist halt die Idee dabei. Es gibt ja Unternehmen wie zum Beispiel bei Samsung, die haben halt irgendwie so ein, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das immer noch haben, aber vor ein paar Jahren hatten sie mal so ein Ding, dass sie quasi so das Prinzip, in Mexiko gibt es auch diese Partei der permanenten Revolution, also was seit Lagerzeit die Regierungspartei war. Dieses Prinzip haben die halt versucht, irgendwie im Unternehmen zu machen, indem sie jedes Jahr im Kalender eingetragen, gibt es eine Re-Org.
Und die dauert dann ja? Bis sich alles wieder eingeschwungen hat, dauert die ja.
Dauert ein paar Wochen oder Monate.
Bullshit. Ich komm ja in vielen großen Firmen vorbei und viele von denen machen irgendwie einmal im Jahr ein Re-Org oder alle zwei Jahre. Und es hat sich noch nie wieder alles gesettelt, bis das nächste Re-Org kommt. Sondern die sind alle in einem Zustand permanenter Konfusion.
Also was ich von Samsung gehört habe, funktioniert das halt so, dass eine Re-Org im Wesentlichen darin besteht, dass sie die Schilder in der Tür einmal umorganisiert hat. Also kann er halt dazu führen, dass es da so paar Friktionen gibt. Aber ich glaube, dass halt dieses Problem zu versuchen, Komplexität rauszukriegen, ist halt natürlich in der Management-Theorie halt ja schon lange da. Aber SpaceX funktioniert auch, glaube ich, deswegen so gut, also beziehungsweise so, wie es jetzt funktioniert. Deswegen, weil es halt auf diese Person in einer Maske zugeschnitten ist. Also, weil die halt einfach...
Also, ein Faktor, den man nicht unterschätzen darf, ist, wenn du weißt, es geht. Also, ein Problem löst sich viel einfacher, wenn du weißt, es ist lösbar. Und wenn du nicht nur explorativ irgendwie rumstocherst, also es gibt da einige tolle Anekdoten. Die eine, habe ich bei SAP gehört, die haben ja HANA, das ist eine In-Memory-Datenbank, und das geht zurück auf ein Uni-Projekt ursprünglich in Südkorea. Und das hat SAP gesehen, hat die dann gekauft, auch später, aber hat erst mal intern ein paar Leute gesagt, hier probiert doch auch mal, und hat ihnen gesagt, okay, pass auf, ihr müsst jetzt nicht so optimiert sein wie die Koreaner, aber hier sind so deren Timings, was die so an Benchmark hinkriegen, wenn ihr da so innerhalb von 50 Prozent seid, so das wäre nicht schlecht. Und dann haben die sich halt hingesetzt, haben da was gehackt, und es stellt sich heraus, dass es einen Übertragungsfehler gab bei diesen Benchmark-Ergebnissen. Und dadurch, dass die aber wussten, in Anführungszeichen, dass diese Benchmarks erreichbar sind, haben sie die dann auch erreicht. Ja, weil sie dachten, wenn die Koreaner das schaffen, dann wissen wir, es geht. Und die waren dann aber am Ende schneller als die Koreaner. Weil sie dachten, ja, wenn die noch schneller sind, dann ist es ja kein Problem. Die Motivation, die davon ausgeht, dass du glaubst, zu wissen, etwas geht, ist so eine der größten Motivationen, die es überhaupt gibt, aus meiner Erfahrung. Das kannst du auch beobachten, wenn dir mein Backup verloren geht von Software, die du geschrieben hast. Und dann musst du die neu schreiben. Und dann denkst du so, oh Gott, da hab ich jetzt zehn Jahre dran gearbeitet. Und dann schreibst du das neu und das dauert drei Wochen. Weil du das Problem jetzt verstanden hast. Und du weißt, es geht. Du weißt nicht nur, es geht, du weißt auch, wie es geht. Also es gibt da viele unverstandene Aspekte. Aber im Grunde ist das eine Sache, die man bei Software schon länger sagt. Du musst das einmal implementieren, dann schmeißt du das weg und dann machst du es noch mal ohne die ganzen Fehler. Aber das Geld will halt keiner ausgeben. Du kennst es ja aus deinen Start-up Geschichten. Es gibt ja diese tolle Anekdote von dir, die ich auch immer wieder in meinen Vorträgen erzähle. So nach dem Motto, ja, die scheitern nie alle, die Start-ups. Und wenn wir zu den 5 Prozent gehören, die nicht scheitern...
Dann schreiben wir es halt nochmal neu.
Genau, aber es macht halt keiner. Sonst wird halt nicht neu geschrieben.
Es stimmt nicht ganz. Es gibt halt schon durchaus...
Facebook ist das geilste Beispiel, was es dafür gibt.
Es gibt einige Beispiele dafür, dass es tatsächlich passiert und dann auch gut ist, dass es passiert. Es gibt auch einige Beispiele dafür, dass es versucht wird und sie dann daran scheitern.
Ja, das Second-System-Effekt.
Also da gibt es halt natürlich in der Software-Management so einige Ansichten zu. Es gibt halt unter anderem diese Ansicht, dass man sagt, wenn du ein Second-System baust, dann baust du es nur mit exakt dem Feature-Set wie das First-System.
Mhm, das ist der Plan.
Ja, und du versuchst halt dabei nicht noch wesentlich mehr Features reinzubauen, sondern es halt nur besser zu machen, was du ohnehin schon gerade hast. Aber der Versuchung dabei, dann halt auch noch alle neue Features erzubauen, widerstehen die wenigsten Leute.
Ja, das geht auch gar nicht. Also es ist ja eine Sache, die ich, ich bereite mich ja gerade auf meinen 36C3-Vortrag vor, da geht es auch um Software-Komplexität. Und das daher, diese ganzen Gedanken, die beschäftigen mich aber schon schon seit einer Weile. Der Second System Effect. Ich habe inzwischen so eine Gradiententheorie, dass ich sage, der Mensch betrachtet das Leben als Optimierungsproblem im mathematischen Sinne und nimmt an, dass es eine glatte Oberfläche ist, auf der man sich einfach dem Gradienten folgend bewegen kann. Und du läufst dann halt der Schwerkraft hinterher und kommst irgendwann beim Ziel deiner Optimierung raus, nämlich in dem Loch. Und das ist auch das erste Verfahren, was man in mathematischen Optimierungs-Sachen benutzt, weil es halt sehr einfach ist. Aber es findet halt nicht die beste Lösung notwendigerweise. Aber der Punkt dabei ist, dass Menschen, sagen wir mal, du bist in einem Raum, dir ist zu kalt, dann gehst du zur Heizung und dann drehst du aber nicht da hin, wo du es haben willst, sondern du drehst auf voll auf. Ja. Und dann wartest du, bis es dir unangenehm warm wird und dann drehst du wieder zurück. Ja, also dieses Overshoot wenden Menschen halt sehr häufig an. Auch wenn du irgendwo hinfahren willst auf der Karte, dann merkst du dir, wo das Limit ist, bis wohin kann ich geradeaus fahren und dann muss ich abbiegen. Ja, so das heißt, du operierst immer am Limit. Wenn du die Geschwindigkeit wählst im Auto, operierst du am Limit bis wohin du dich sicher fühlst und dann gehst du wieder bis hier zurück. So und das funktioniert halt nicht immer. Also die Sachen, wo es nicht funktioniert, sind sowas wie zum Beispiel Drogen- oder Alkoholabhängigkeit. Da geht es zurück halt nicht oder du merkst es zu spät. Und Komplexität ist aus meiner Sicht genau so was. Also während du Komplexität aufhäufst, merkst du nicht, ob du zu weit gegangen bist oder nicht. Das merkst du halt erst später. Und Security ist genauso ein Ding. Du merkst halt nicht, ob deine Software unsicher ist, bis jemand eindringt. Und wenn du dann guckst, ob du das Problem, über das hier gerade eingedrungen wurde, noch woanders hast, dann hast du es auch überall anders, normalerweise. Das heißt, ich glaube, das ist ein Teil davon, wie Menschen funktionieren, dass man sich am Limit bewegt. Und eine der Beobachtungen ist, wenn ein neues Verfahren rauskommt, um Komplexität besser handhabbar zu machen. Also zum Beispiel Modularisierung oder objektorientierte Programmierung. Waren so zwei Ansätze, die halt irgendwann rauskamen. Und dann haben die Leute aber nicht dieselbe Software, wie vorher geschrieben, nur besser. Sondern sie haben größere Software geschrieben. Ja, weil ich glaube, das ist ein inhärentes, ein inhärentes Ding im Menschen. Wenn du glaubst, du kannst weitergehen, dann gehst du auch weiter. Dann nutzt du nicht die Technik, um bessere, kleinere Software zu schreiben. Sondern du schreibst dann halt wieder am Limit und dann ist die Software halt entsprechend größer. Und das kann man ja auch beobachten. Man sieht, Software wird ja praktisch nie kleiner, sondern wird immer nur immer größer und komplexer. Und ich glaube, das ist keine Eigenschaft von Software und auch nicht eine Eigenschaft von Software-Entwicklung, sondern ich glaube, das ist fundamental bei Menschen. Aber ich habe keine Beweise dafür.
Also was mich dabei eigentlich ja primär interessiert ist, wenn Leute diese Erkenntnisse halt versuchen zu weaponisen. Also so den dafür zu sorgen, dass halt irgendwie in denen eine Komplexität erschaffen wird oder existierende Komplexität dafür benutzt wird, um mit dem Versprechen von Einfachheit, von einfachen Lösungen, einfachen Erklärungen, einfachen Abhilfen dann halt irgendwie an die Macht zu kommen. Also wie jetzt gerade in den UK zum Beispiel, wo halt irgendwie dieses Johnson halt dieses ganze super komplexe Brexit-Thema auf Get Brexit Done runtergebrochen hat. Und halt einfach nur so nicht mal mehr irgendwie darüber redet, was jetzt eigentlich dieser Brexit bedeutet, was irgendwie dann am Ende dabei rauskommt.
Ich glaube, das ist den Leuten inzwischen auch echt egal.
Genau.
Nur noch, dass es vorbei ist.
Der hat sich halt einfach ermüdet. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein…
Nein, nicht nur er, auch die Theresa May, die sind jetzt auch alle nicht in einer Position gewesen, die man jetzt irgendwie beneiden würde. Aber das ist auch eine Sache aus der Softwareentwicklung, die man übernehmen kann, dass man sieht, Komplexität wegzukapseln und zu abstrahieren. Das ist so das typische Modell, was man macht, um Komplexität beharrbar zu machen. Und das funktioniert auch ganz gut in den meisten Fällen, aber manchmal halt nicht. Also die meisten Sicherheitsprobleme kommen daher, dass man verschiedene Schichten hat, die weg abstrahierte Komplexität haben und die Annahmen nicht sauber kommuniziert hat, weil man sie vielleicht gar nicht kannte. Und dann nimmt die Schicht eins an, Schicht zwei macht was und Schicht zwei macht aber was subtil anderes und dann hast du ein Sicherheitsloch. Also weg abstrahieren funktioniert nur, wenn man dann nicht irgendwie Sollbruchstellen einbaut. Und das ist sehr häufig in in Software zumindest. Ich vermute, das wird in Vertragsverhandlungen wie Brexit genauso sein. Da hast du halt deine einfache Idee, aber die Details sind halt sehr komplex, weil dann heißt es ok. Also die Idee würde an der Stelle sagen A, aber wir wollen eigentlich B. Also machen wir hier eine Ausnahme. Und dann hast du halt aber die Komplexität am Ende nicht reduziert, sondern das sieht nur reduziert aus. Naja, also ich meine, der größte Komplexitätsreduktionsautomat, den ich kenne, ist ja, dass man sagt, in Deutschland, wenn dir jemand eine Euler gibt und da stehen Sachen drin, die zu erwarten gewesen wären.
End-User-Lessons Agreement.
Genau, also so ein Software irgendwie, wenn sie die Software benutzen wollen, müssen sie hier noch schnell zustimmen. Und das ist nach dem Kauf der Software, dann ist das halt ungültig, was da drin steht, weil man nicht nach dem Kaufen noch Sachen nachreichen darf. So das ist eine Sache, die Komplexität ungemein reduziert oder in einer AGB, in allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen dürfen keine irgendwie überraschenden Klauseln zu Lasten des Kunden drin sein und so. Also man kann da ja Dinge tun. Das ist ja nicht so, dass wir dem einfach ausgeliefert wären.
Naja, wobei natürlich die Frage ist, ob man sowas auch für Vertragswerke der Komplexität eines Brexit machen kann. Ich habe ja so die leise Vermutung, dass nicht.
Ich denke ja, dass das absichtlich so komplex gemacht wurde, weil man ja gerade verhindern wollte, dass Leute austreten.
Es gibt da halt schon reale Komplexität, die halt einfach damit zu tun hat, dass Standardisierung im Sinne von Übereinstimmung auf technische Geflogenheiten und Gegebenheiten, die es auf allen möglichen Ebenen gibt in der EU, dazu führt, dass du halt einfach Produkte Austauschbarer machst und damit halt eben tatsächlich, ob du das mit einem gemeinsamen Markt möglich machst, weil du halt einfach eine, also ja, sagen wir mal, Kommodifizierung dazu führt, dass ein Handel einfacher wird. Und dass unter diesem Deckmantel natürlich noch jede Menge andere Sachen stannisiert wurden, die überhaupt nicht hätten stannisiert werden müssen. Klar ist es so. Andererseits gibt es natürlich sowas wie irgendwie Umwelt- und Arbeitsschutz, wo man sagen muss, okay, da ist es jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so verkehrt, dass die EU sagt, okay, wir wollen halt da kein Dumping haben, sondern wir wollen halt, dass irgendwie alle zumindest so grob dem selben Standard folgen.
Oder Fischerei ist ja auch so ein riesen Streitpunkt. Aber ich denke mir, Das ist wie in der Softwareentwicklung, wenn die Leute die Fehlerbehandlung nicht ordentlich machen, weil sie denken, das passiert schon nicht. Genau das sehen wir jetzt gerade in der EU. Wenn man sich da von vornherein Gedanken gemacht hätte, wie man das so organisiert, dass ein Austritt wie sinnvoll möglich ist, dann wäre das auch kein Problem gewesen. Hätte man machen können.
Das war aber auch nicht gewollt.
Ja, eben. Daher ist das jetzt nicht, daher ist das jetzt nicht irgendwie, oh mein Gott, ist alles so komplex, sondern das ist selbstzugefügte Komplexität. Hat jemand eine große Schrotflinte genommen, auf den Fuß gezielt und abgedrückt?
Naja, wobei jetzt die Frage natürlich ist, was machen die denn jetzt? Er hat ja auch schon mal erwähnt, Dominic Cummings, der Berater von Johnson, der halt so das Mastermind hinter der Brexit-Kampagne war und jetzt wahrscheinlich auch den jetzigen Wahlkampf geführt hat und dessen Ideen sind ja interessant in dem Sinne, dass er sagt, er will halt einen... Im chinesischen Sinne? Interessant im Sinne von möglichst uninteressanten Zeiten leben. Der hat ja so einen Ansatz zu sagen, okay, wir können diese ganze Komplexität halt nur noch mit quasi Experten-Regierungen bewältigen, die über alle Daten verfügen und über Machine-Intelligenz verfügen, also...
Kybernetik.
Genau.
Ja, Kybernetik 2.0, was gerade passiert, ne?
4.0.
Die KI wird's machen. That's what I say.
Ja, ist ja mit AI, ne? Und dessen Ansicht dazu ist ja, dass man halt besonders schnelle, hoch talentierte Individuen braucht, die über diese Technologie verfügen, mit der sie sehen können, was wirklich passiert in Echtzeit, um dann halt darauf zu reagieren. Und wenn man das hat, dann kann man halt auch viel mehr interessante und riskante Sachen machen. Also man kann zum Beispiel mit Gentechnik experimentieren, obwohl man weiß, dass es möglicherweise risikoreich ist, weil man ja dann schnell reagieren kann. Und wenn man sich so dessen Schrift tun, muss man ja schon sagen, also seine Words auf Text und seinen Blog anguckt, dann hat er zum einen schon verstanden, dass es dieses Komplexitätsproblem gibt. Zum anderen hat er durchaus ein gutes Verständnis dafür, wie man diese Komplexität verbirgt. Also seine Kampagnen-Slogans, also mit Brexit zum Beispiel. Das ist auch schön formuliert.
Es geht halt nicht darum, die loszuwerden, sondern da irgendwie eine schöne Decke drüber.
Also dieses Take Back Control oder Get Brexit Done. Ja, ja. Also wenn man das unter Propaganda-Handwerkaspekten betrachtet, sind das halt absolute Meisterwerke. Also es gibt wenig, was in neuerer Zeit so durchschlagend simplifizierende Propaganda ist, wo man halt einfach so dieses ich will da jetzt nicht weiter drüber nachdenken, nein, das ist mir viel zu komplex, das ist mir egal, ich will, dass das endlich aufhört.
Genau, so ist gut.
Das halt jetzt macht, was getan werden muss. Das tut, was getan werden muss. Und das halt, das meine ich halt mit Macht. Also weil sozusagen du die Komplexität so weit hochfährst, dass alle zwei Tage nach davon sich nicht mehr damit auseinandersetzen wollen. Und du dann dieses, also okay, wir kümmern uns für dich darum. Also du musst dich da nicht weiter so wie, wie get it done so. Also diese, dieses.
Get Brexit done so the country can move on.
Das ist halt einfach so eine aktive Benutzung von Komplexität als politische Waffe. Und man kennt es ja so aus irgendwie so Mittelalter Herrscher Szenarien, wo am Ende halt der Berater, der halt mit der Komplexität noch klar kam, oder die Berater, die mit der Komplexität noch klar kam, eigentlich regiert haben. Und für den König oder die Königin halt nur so Abstraktionen bereitgestellt haben.
Sprecht Glasen.
Ja, bzw. halt einfach so, denen gesagt haben, ihr müsst nur so ungefähr entscheiden, in welche Richtung ihr wollt, und wir kümmern uns dann um die Details. Das ist ja eine alte Form der Regierung schon immer gewesen, dass es halt dieses Beraterwesen gab, die dann die eigentliche Macht hatten, was halt die Staatssekretäre sind.
Sie haben nur nicht die eigentliche Kohle rausgetragen damals, aber ansonsten schon vergleichbar mit heute.
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass viele von diesen Beratern jetzt auch nicht arm gestorben sind.
Nö, arm gestorben nicht, aber jetzt nicht im Vergleich zu dem König.
Ja, also ich meine, die haben gehabt auch Berater, die komplette Königstime übernommen haben, also zum Beispiel die Hausmeier bei den Merovingern. Die Merovinger waren halt so ein Königsgeschlecht, so ungefähr in der Größenordnung, wo jetzt gerade so Frankreich ist. Und die waren halt irgendwann so ein bisschen unklar, ob die nicht wollten oder nicht konnten, jedenfalls nicht in der Lage, ihr Reichtar irgendwie zu managen. Und haben das halt irgendwie in ihren Hausmeiern, also Ähnlichkeit zu Hausmeistern nicht von ungefähr überlassen, halt sich um die Details zu kümmern. Und da am Ende, also nur irgendwie relativ kurze Zeit später, gehörte denen dann halt einfach irgendwie das Reich. Und die haben halt ihre eigenen Adelsgeschlechter geformt, mit denen sie dann weiter regiert haben. Und also es war durchaus schon einträglich so. Also wenn halt die, weil es gab auch durchaus eine Menge Königshäuser, wo Kinder auf den Thron gesetzt wurden. Na so, wo halt irgendwie dann...
Damit die Verwalter durchregieren könnten.
Genau. Das heißt, so Komplikitätsmanagement als Machtmittel ist halt durchaus ein nicht seltenes Spiel. Und ich glaube, dass diese Brexit-Nummer jetzt, wo halt dieser Versuch von, wir machen eine super komplexe Materie, runter auf ein Schlagwort.
Meinst du, das ist der Feldversuch? Und das läuft aber jetzt immer so?
Wollte ich so sehen. Ich bin gespannt, was Tom sich ausdenkt für einen Wahlkampf. Bin echt gespannt.
Meinst du, da muss sich was ausdenken? Der macht einfach... Ich mein, man hat ja jetzt gesehen, dieses Ding, als er da den jüdischen Immobilienhain in diesem Vortrag gesagt hat, ihr habt gar keine Wahl, ihr müsst mich wählen. Wenn ihr nicht mich wählt, dann kommt die Demokrats ran und dann nimmt euch Bernie euer Geld weg. Das ist halt seine Message. Das kam jetzt nicht so gut an. Aber ich glaube, so sieht er das auch.
Ja, klar. Vielleicht sieht das ja so. Na gut, die Ami-Wahlen, da müssen wir dann zu gegebener Zeit noch mal irgendwie eine Sendung zu machen.
Tja, und hey, wenn der Trump weg ist, dann musst du vielleicht wieder eine Snorchow mit mir machen. Das war deine Ansage, dass da ein Trump drin ist.
Das ist korrekt. Apollika Glaube ist eher der Pfalz als ein Win. Also ich hab leider die Befürchtung, dass die...
Meinst du, der macht mehr als zwei Abendszeit? Machen wir die schon mal?
Wir haben ja nicht gesagt, ob es irgendwie Donald Trump sein muss.
Oh nee!
Also wenn jetzt endlich eine... Werde jetzt...
Präsidentin Ivanka.
Werde jetzt nicht anfängt, die Delastie aufzumachen erfolgreich, dann bin ich raus. Na ja. Ja. Hat man noch was an Themen?
Ich glaube, das war's.
Das war's. Sind wir durch?
Aber wir sollten nicht auf Trump innen kommen.
Irgendetwas anderes muss gehen, ja. Ach so, ja. Ich hab noch ein schönes zu Komplexität. Den sollten wir vielleicht noch in dir verlinken. Die Amerikaner und ihre aktuellen Flugzeugträger. Die Amerikaner bauen ja gerade neue Flugzeugträger. Also Flugzeugträger brauchen wir ja so als Großmacht, glauben die Amis. Also außer ihnen glauben das, glaube ich, noch die Chinesen.
Den Russen ist gerade ihr Flugzeugträger ange-
Ja, den Russen ist mal wieder ihrer angekuckelt und alle anderen haben irgendwie beschlossen, dass eigentlich irgendwie eher, naja, gut, also jedenfalls ein paar Flugzeugträger werden noch gebaut. Die Amis jedenfalls haben irgendwie ein neues Modell, nämlich die George Ford-Klasse ist jetzt noch mal ihr neuester Flugzeugträger. Und das Ganze, wenn man so die Berichte darüber liest, die sich jetzt so ein bisschen visionieren, so 30 Prozent. Also es liest sich so ein bisschen so, also die Berichte erinnert mich so ein bisschen an BR, das ist halt offenbar so ein schwimmender BR für 13 Milliarden Dollar.
Wo sie aber am Termin festgehalten haben.
Wo sie am Termin festgehalten haben.
Das heißt, jetzt haben sie einen Flugzeugträger ohne Main Guns. Weil der Mechanismus, um die Munition hochzuladen, war ein neuartiger magnetischer irgendwie Blar. Und das Feuern wäre auch über irgendwie Railgun gewesen.
Nee, die Railgun war in einem anderen Schiff. Nee, das Problem bei dem Flugzeugträger ist, dass die Katapulte, um die Flugzeuge loszuschießen, haben sie auch als quasi so ein elektromagnetisches...
Ja, das war ja genau, Railgun. Also elektromagnetisch angetrieben und nicht wie bisher mit Dampf.
Genau. Und genauso halt, wenn sie das Ding wieder landen, also wenn sie halt irgendwie das Flugzeug bremsen, da haben sie sich auch ein neues System eingebaut, was halt irgendwie viel weniger Platz brauchen sollte als das bisherige. Die funktionieren beide noch nicht so gut. Und dann haben sie offensichtlich, weil sie halt Gewicht sparen wollten, haben sie die Verteilspannung an Bord erhöht. Das heißt also bisher, was glaube ich, war zu 4 Kilovolt, die sie halt als Verteilspannung für die wesentlichen großen Systeme an Bord hatten, aus dem Reaktor, also von der Turbine vom Reaktor. Und jetzt haben sie die auf 13 Kilovolt erhöht. Und denkt man sich so, naja, das war eigentlich ganz gut so, braucht man halt irgendwie weniger dicke Kabel, um dieselbe Leistung zu transportieren, ist eigentlich keine so schlechte Idee. Hochspannung halt. Hat halt nur das Problem, dass alles, was man da so schalten will, ist halt irgendwie viel schwieriger, weil du halt in so einem feuchten Schiff hast, du dann halt irgendwie Funken strecken und irgendwie musst irgendwie auf die Isolierung achten und so weiter. Das ist schon alles ein bisschen anstrengender, so mit 13 Kilovolt. Und einer der Effekte davon ist offenbar, dass die Katapulte, also zum Flugzeug los schießen, nicht einzeln abschalten können, wenn nur einer repariert werden muss. Das Problem dabei ist, aber...
Das passiert wohl ständig bei den Dampfdingern, aber du musst halt nur einen von drei dann irgendwie ausfallen lassen.
Nee, bei den elektronischen Dingern passiert es halt irgendwie sehr viel häufiger als bei den Dampfdingern.
Ja, aber selbst bei den Dampfdingern muss es da ständig der Fall......
da häufiger ran, genau.
Ja, aber es macht halt nichts, weil du hast halt noch die beiden anderen.
Genau. Und so können sie halt nur alle Katapulte abschalten, um eins zu reparieren. Das war halt jetzt irgendwie in so einem Szenario, wo so ein Flugzeugträger möglicherweise irgendwie...
Ach komm, Flugzeugträger muss doch gerne Flugzeuge starten und dann lassen können.
Ja, nee, eigentlich nicht. Ist halt eigentlich völlig überflüssig. Naja, jedenfalls ist denen da wohl so ein bisschen auf das Komplexitätsmanagement weggerannt, weil sie zu versucht haben, zu viel neuen Shit auf einmal zu integrieren.
Ja, aber das ist eigentlich im gesamten Militär hört man immer wieder solche Stories. Der F-35 war ja ein einziges Gruselkabinett solcher Stories. So von wegen, ja, da haben wir alles noch mal neu gemacht. Und diese Düsen-Jets sind inzwischen so, dass sie gar nicht mehr unassistiert fliegen können, weil da brauchst du Thrust-Vectoring. Da muss ein Computer irgendwie nach korrigieren. Und wenn der Computer nicht geht, dann geht halt das Flugzeug nicht.
Das war aber schon bei der F-117, so dem ersten Tankkampfflugzeug. Da haben sie ja vor einer Weile das Manual declassified. Und da gibt es halt so diese schöne Page. Was tust du, wenn der Bordcomputer aus ist? Also alle, ich glaube, drei, haben drei Bordcomputers.
Also drückst du den Eject-Knopf her.
Ja.
Geil.
Die sagen halt, dieses Flugzeug ist ohne Computer-Assistenz nicht fliegbar. Wenn irgendwie auch die letzte Redundanz beim Bordcomputer ausgefallen ist, ziehst du den großen Hebel zwischen deinen Beinen und... Ja.
Und hoffst, dass du nicht über ein feines Gebiet bist.
Ja, oder dass du halt rauskommst. Na gut, denn...
Wo wir gerade bei Komplexität waren, die Schlagzeile im Moment ist, dass der Gipfel in Madrid, der Klimagipfel, komplett gescheitert ist. Ja, das war ja zu erwarten, oder?
Das gibt doch anders zur Hoffnung, ne?
Gut, dann hoffen wir, dass es noch eine nächste Sendung gibt von Alternativlos, bevor uns die Komplexität alle umgebracht hat.
Ja, ich geh mal davon aus, das wird schon klappen. Ja, also wenn ihr Lust habt zu spenden, wir haben da noch so einen Patreon-Button und unsere Crypto-Coin-Challenge läuft auch irgendwie noch weiter. Wir konnten diese Sendung leider noch nicht auswerten. Ich muss da noch das Wallet recoveren, aber das wird schon.
War mir nicht schwach, Frank. Ey, und ich sag noch, keine Cryptoscheiße.
Kannst du auch manchmal recht haben. Na gut, also in diesem Sinne vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir wünschen euch dann ansonsten noch irgendwie frohe Festtage und so weiter. Und keine Ahnung, ob wir versprechen, irgendwie nächstes Jahr mehr Sendung zu machen. Wir können es ja mal zumindest.
Versprechen kann man es immer, aber skandistisch ist das die Frage.
Ich muss ja mal gucken.
Wir tun unser Bestes.
Ja, ansonsten wie immer die Links, dann tun wir irgendwie in die Show Notes. Ähm, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.